und journalistisch begleitet von meinem
kollegen gerd joachim von fr
wenn ein ordnungsruf zu unrecht erteilt
wurde oder eine mildere maßnahme
angezeigt ja vielen dank hans werner
fittkau wir sind zurück im deutschen
bundestag in diesen sekunden hat gerade
beatrix von storch von der afg einen
ordnungsruf und frau kassiert die
integrine frau von storch hat ein foto
gemacht in der debatte vor hin dieses
foto ist im internet erschien das ist
ausdrücklich gegen die hausordnung hier
dass frau von storch wurde jetzt
aufgefordert aus das foto von ihrem
gerät zu löschen und der den tweet zu
löschen zu ihrer verteidigung gesagt sie
habe das in den foto gar nicht
eingestellt wie sie es dann ins internet
gekommen das ist momentan nicht
aufzuklären petra pau jedenfalls bleibt
erstmal bei ihrem ordnungsruf gegen der
arzt ist beatrix von storch so und wir
warten in diesen sekunden auf die
aktuelle stunde von der cdu csu
beantragt und mit dem titel von der
bundesregierung angekündigte kehrtwende
bei energiepreisen so schnell wie
möglich richtig und unbürokratisch
umzusetzen
und
die cdu wird auch den ersten redner
stellen johannes steiniger wird hier die
aktuelle stunde gleich eröffnen wenn die
abgeordneten hier platz genommen haben
zwischendurch am sie nichts verpasst
meine damen und herren es gab einige
abstimmung ohne aussprache
und die wahl eines mitglieds
ist hier aufgerufen worden die aktion
haben jetzt bis 15 uhr 40 zeit ihre
stimme einzuwerfen aber konzentrieren
wir uns auf die aktuelle stunde johannes
steiniger der erste redner für die
cdu/csu
der frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen wir alle merken es das
leben wird teurer das merken wir wenn
wir tanken gehen an der zapfsäule das
merken wir bei jedem einkauf den wir im
supermarkt machen und wir werden es auch
wenn wir zur miete wohnen am ende des
jahres merken wenn die nachzahlungen
kommen dann wird es für viele ganz
besonders schlimm werden wir sehen also
das leben von vielen bürgerinnen und
bürger in unserem land ändert sich
manche müssen sich nur einschränken aber
bei ganz vielen herrschte große sorge
dass sich eben nicht nur nicht
einschränken sondern dass am ende des
monats nicht mehr genug geld da ist um
diese hohen preise dann auch zu bezahlen
wir erleben eine rekord inflation
7,3 prozent im märz seit 40 jahren
hatten wir nicht mehr solche zahlen und
mir ist es jetzt in neun jahren
bundestag das erste mal passiert dass
ich eine petition eines gemeinderats aus
meinem wahlkreis bekommen habe die
kleine gemeinde beiden teilt die sich
bei sich vor ort mit bei den kommunalen
bei den ehrenamtlichen dafür einsetzen
wollen hier dass wir im deutschen
bundestag handeln das zeigt aus meiner
sicht dass es hier wirklich fünf nach
zwölf ist und ich fordere und wir
fordern die ampel auf jetzt endlich zu
reagieren und die werden jetzt gleich
sagen in der debatte werden sie jetzt
gleich sagen ja wir haben doch gestern
da was verabschiedet und auch in den
letzten wochen immer mal wieder was
gemacht aber das muster das muster was
wir sehen das muster dieser ampel ist
immer gleich die ampel reagiert zu spät
sie macht zu wenig und wenn sie etwas
machen dann machen sie es so
bürokratisch dass es am schluss sehr
viel mehr kosten noch produziert ich
würde mir wünschen meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren dass auf dieser
koalition nicht nur fortschritts
koalition braucht steht sondern dass sie
die sofort diesen fortschritt auch mit
pet diese ps auf die straße bringt denn
zu fortschritt gehört auch schnelligkeit
dazu und wir sind eine wissen als
opposition wir sind als union eine
konstruktive opposition wir weisen auf
diese themen seit vielen monaten hin wir
haben schon im letzten jahr auf das
thema hohe inflation hier in debatten
hingewiesen da habe ich noch gehört ja
das gibt es doch gar nicht das wird sich
in den nächsten monaten
gleichen wir sehen heute dass es falsch
wir haben zum thema hohe energiepreise
schon vor monaten hier einen antrag
eingebracht der wurde von ihnen
abgelehnt ich selbst habe hier im
dezember kurz vor weihnachten zum thema
kalte progression gesprochen und gesagt
dass sie dort etwas machen müssen sie
mache nichts und das liegt daran weil
sich die fdp nicht durchsetzen konnte im
koalitionsvertrag der begriff kalter
progression kommt im koalitionsvertrag
nicht vor und deswegen gleichen sie es
anders als wir es früher gemacht haben
nicht aus und das dicke ende wird jetzt
ja kommen das dicke ende wird jetzt
kommen weil jetzt die tarifrunden
anstehen und dann wird es so sein dass
die lohnerhöhung die wir bei den tarifen
sehen aufgefressen werden tun sie etwas
dagegen nicht nur indem sie den
grundfreibetrag erhöhen sondern sie
müssen auch was bei den eckwerten machen
dazu fordern wir sie auf und jetzt haben
sie ja einiges an ankündigungen und
maßnahmen was sie uns jetzt in den
letzten tagen hier auch vorstellen dass
eine haben sie im grunde genommen von
uns
kopiert das andere ist super
bürokratisch und handwerklich schlecht
gemacht sie führen einen familienbonus
100 euro wir haben vor wenigen wochen
hier vorgeschlagen einen kinderbonus zu
machen von 150 da bleiben sie hinter
unseren forderung zurück ich kann
übrigens auch nicht mehr ertragen wenn
sie sich hier abfeiern auch gestern habe
ich ihren fraktionsvorsitzende christian
tür bei bild gesehen der sich da ab
gefeiert hat was man für eine große
entlastung hier vor sich hat jetzt
gucken wir uns einfach nur mal an was
die und und was die union in den letzten
jahren gemacht hat wir haben den
kinderbonus zweimal gemacht wir haben in
zwei mal für 150 euro gemacht wir haben
allein in den beiden familien
entlastungs gesetzen über 20 milliarden
euro entlastung gemacht und sie feiern
sich jetzt hier mit diesen dingen ab das
ist nicht in ordnung zweiter punkt
energie steuer bei der energiesteuern
finden wir es gut dass sie unseren
vorschlag aufnehmen diese zu reduzieren
aber wir hätten gerne dass ich es nicht
nur für drei monate machen sondern dass
sie unseren vorschlag aufnehmen und dies
eben für zwei jahren machen denn eins
ist doch klar diese krise wird nicht in
drei monaten zu ende sein jetzt das
thema energie geld wir hatten eine
anhörung dazu im finanzausschuss und das
war schon sehr erschreckt wenn man sich
anschaut was für einen rattenschwanz
diese 300 euro dieses jahr auszahlen
wollen nach sich zieht es kommt zu spät
und ist ungenügend sie vergessen im
übrigen auch viele sie vergessen die
studenten und die rentner aber am
allerschlimmsten und es wundert mich
dann schon wenn die fdp an in einer
solchen bundesregierung beteiligt ist
sie schaffen hier ein bürokratiemonster
heute handelsblatt die bezifferung der
bürokratie kosten allein für das energie
geld eine milliarde euro die
steuerverwaltung in den bundesländern
werden mit
550 millionen bürokratiekosten mehr
belastet ein wahnsinn wenn man sich das
anschaut und manchmal muss man dann ja
etwas lachen ich habe dann gesehen der
finanzminister hat sich zitieren lassen
dass man das so bürokratie schonend wie
möglich umsetzen will ich frage mich
manchmal was die fdp als sie noch in der
opposition gewesen ist zu solchen
gesetzen gesagt hätte ich kann es mir
gut vorstellen und das sagen wir ihnen
jetzt auch von daher kommen sie hier in
die puschen und kommen sie am auftrag
nach
johannes steiniger bei der erste rede
aktuellen stunde die von der cdu csu
beantragt ist von der bundesregierung
angekündigte kehrtwende bei
energiepreisen so schnell wie möglich
richtig und unbürokratisch umsetzen so
lautet der titel und die nächste
rednerin ist die sprecherin für
klimaschutz und energie der spd in nina
scheer
ich finde das immer wieder erschreckend
mit welchen platten versuchen sie aus
den cdu csu heraus anträge vorlegen und
überschreiben das sei jetzt irgend etwas
neues was wir nach gemacht hätten
meistens lässt sich durch keats durch
pressemitteilung ziemlich schnell
nachvollziehen dass sie mit ziemlicher
sicherheit und regelmäßigkeit immer 14
monate nach hier schon eingebrachten
entwürfen oder jedenfalls schon mit
ecopy verhafteten entwürfen dann
vorschläge unterbreiten insofern ist es
wenn es nicht so tragisch wäre die
situation in der wir uns befinden
angesichts der dringlichkeit auch
entlastungen zu schaffen wäre es
wirklich ein treppenwitz was sie von der
aus ihren reihen heraus immer wieder auf
die tagesordnung setzen und dazu ist
eben dann auch keine aktuelle stunde zu
schade und ich möchte einfach noch mal
dass es vielleicht eine kleine
philosophie stunde jetzt aber einfach
mal auf der zunge zergehen lassen
welchen titel sie gewählt haben von der
bundesregierung
angekündigte kehrtwende
bei energiepreisen so schnell wie
möglich richtig und unbürokratisch
umsetzen
also was heißt denn eigentlich
angekündigte kehrtwende
ich wüsste jetzt nicht dass wir irgend
eine kehrtwende angekündigt haben weil
es ja schließlich ein entwicklung ist
sie sich keiner ausgesucht hat
es geht also und dass man dinge die sich
ereignen aus verschiedensten gründen
einmal waren die korona pandemie hatten
und immer noch haben aber enorme
einbrüche hatten in der wirtschaft und
deswegen auch reduktionen in den energie
nachfragen da waren darauf haben sich
die märkte eingestellt dann sind wir
wieder zurückgekommen in einen wachstums
in eine wachstumsphase darauf müssten
die märkte erstmal reagieren und darüber
haben wir auch effekt an den
rentenmärkten gehabt und auch
preissteigerungen gehabt also wo
bitteschön möchten sich das würdige
kehrtwende anknüpfen es ist mir nicht
klar
insofern angekündigt habe ich schon gar
nicht zu ende ist auch nicht in dieser
phase zu erkennen weil wir schließlich
handeln und wir machen entlastungspaket
dort wo sie zielgerichtet angebracht
sind und wo wir es auch für sitzen
halten
zudem unterstellen sie mit diesem ding
das energiepreise irgendwas garantiert
dass sein irgendetwas vom himmel
gefallen dass es in zusammenhang mit den
fossilen energie märkten steht es ist
besonders
irritierend dass sie das in der heutigen
zeit immer noch meinen dass man von
garantierten energiepreisen im fossilen
energie system ausgehen könnte das ist
also auch da schon mal wieder ein großes
missverständnis was sie schon mit dem
titel in die diskussion bringen zudem
wollen sie es richtig und unbürokratisch
umsetzen richtig ja was ist denn in der
politik richtig wenn es ein ereignisse
gibt für die es keine schablone gibt es
geht auch darum die situation zu
analysieren
und wenn sie anderen den raum stellt sie
waren etwas richtig machen bestellungen
würden dass sie sich überhaupt nicht mit
der analyse auseinandergesetzt haben
erfuhren sie gar nicht zu diesem
seltsamen schwammigen und auch wirklich
wenig so zu mir waren begriff in dieser
überschrift gelangen insofern
mit der bürokratie ja das ist ja auch
immer so ein kampfbegriff wir wollen ja
schließlich auch etwas gerecht machen
und wenn man etwas gerecht ausgestalten
will dann muss man auch einzelfall muss
man auch einzelfallgerechtigkeit
schaffen das ist aber bei generell
regeländerungen regeln wie sie nun mal
gesetzt mit sich bringen und wenn man es
schnell auf den weg bringen möchte gar
nicht so einfach deswegen haben wir mit
zwei entlastungspaket sehr gut
austariert in unteren von über 30
milliarden euro die das insgesamt
umfasst
verschiedene gruppierungen in der
bevölkerung fokussiert und zielgenau
geschaut wie kann man da entlasten beim
heizkostenzuschuss war im energiebereich
haben der entlaste dem kinderbonus
entlastet einiges ist schon auch ein
gesetz einiges auf den weg ich habe eine
lange liste die sich in 53 sekunden
jetzt gar nicht lange unter lesen lässt
aber die können sie alle diese fabrik
mit dem zwei entlastungspaket die wir
haben erst heute machen wir noch einen
weiteren schritt mit der eeg umlagen
absinken die wir heute noch beschließen
werden auch die wird an entlastung
bringen sie ist zugleich auch wichtig
mit blick auf die energiewende weil wir
da einen anreiz kriegen für für
wärmepumpen die damit attraktiver werden
das ist also auch zielgerichtet
dahingehend tierversuche und habe es
auch geschafft mit den entlastungs
paketen sowohl schnelligkeit
hinzubekommen zugleich aber auch
gerechtigkeit war ja nicht die
großverdiener hier entlastet werden
müssen sondern es sind maßnahmen tagen
die natürlich dort ansetzen wo auch
besondere bedarfe sind aber da muss man
die auch analysieren analyse bedeutet
auch bürokratie aber die muss aber dem
rechtsstaat wo es gerecht zugehen will
auch etwas wert sein und in diesem sinne
ist auch dass mit den sind auch die
entlastungs pakete zu verstehen und
genauso sind ihre maßnahmen auch
fehlgeleitet oder ihre installierte
ihrer aktuellen stunde und das was sie
damit verfolgen auch fehlgeleitet
vielleicht darf ich noch mit dem letzten
satz immer noch schließen sie haben
jetzt gestern versucht in der csu noch
die zehnjährige etwas zu abzumildern sie
steht aber nachwievor zu dieser 10h
regelung sie haben immer noch nicht
kapiert dass die energiepolitischen
erkennen hätten habe ihrer fraktion nur
eins versprechen nämlich dass sie eine
verteuerung garantie sind und damit
möchte ich schließen vielen dank
nina scheer war das für die spd
und der nächste redner kommt von der afg
bernd schattner
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
bereits am 18 februar diesen jahres
forderte die ich an dieser stelle in
meinem antrag mit der drucksache 707 aus
20 die mehrwertsteuer für kraftstoffe
und heizöl auf sieben prozent zu
reduzieren und die co2 steuer
abzuschaffen mit dieser maßnahme werden
zum damaligen zeitpunkt ein sofortiger
preisnachlass von rund 37 cent je liter
kraftstoff umsetzbar gewesen hätten sie
damals unserem antrag zugestimmt
bräuchten wir heute nicht ihre aktuelle
stunde um die bürger wären bereits seit
monaten entlastet
sechs tage später am 24 februar begann
der krieg in der ukraine in der folge
überschlugen sich die preise für
kraftstoffe ebenso steigen seit diesem
zeitpunkt die preise für lebensmittel
nahezu täglich an ein ende dieser
preisspirale ist noch lange nicht in
sicht ganz im gegenteil der kämpfen
bereits jetzt wieder mit
versorgungsengpässen und lehrern
regalreihen in den supermärkten in folge
dieser preis explosionen forderten wir
am 6 april als raf die
bundestagsfraktion aufdruck server 10 34
aus 20 die mehrwertsteuer und die co2
steuer bei kraftstoffen komplett zu
streichen und ebenso lebensmittel von
der mehrwertsteuer zu befreien damals
ließ die koalition diese forderungen
weit von sich nur drei wochen später hat
minister özdemir offensichtlich den
vorschlag der afg aufgenommen und
forderten uns selbst die absenkung der
mehrwertsteuer auf lebensmittel
immerhin
es gibt auch lernfähige grüne hätte ich
persönlich nicht so nicht gedacht
auch dieser antrag von der einzigen
echten oppositionsparteien deutschen
bundestag zur entlastung unserer bürger
und des mittelstandes wurde wieder durch
alle anderen parteien abgelehnt mit
anderen worten bereits zweimal wurde ich
hier durch die sogenannten
volksvertreter ihren eigenen wählern
eine deutliche finanzielle entlastung
verwehrt und was tut unsere regierung
für die menschen im land minister habeck
und kanzler scholz sorgen mit massiven
wirtschaftssanktionen gegen russland und
waffenlieferungen für die ukraine dafür
dass die heimische wirtschaft mit der
dadurch steigenden energiepreisen enorm
belastet wird und die angst vor einem
dritten weltkrieg berechtigt zunimmt
herr scholz gerade durch ihre jugend
kontakte zur fdj müssten sie doch
eigentlich noch den wahlspruch schwerter
zu pflugscharen kennen kriege löst man
eben nicht mit waffengewalt sondern mit
diplomatie
zurück zum thema entlastung unserer
bürger das jetzt von der regierung
beschlossene maßnahmenpaket zur
entlastung der deutschen bürger lässt
sich mit einem satz zusammenfassen zu
wenig zu spät und zu bürokratisch
hätte dieses hohe haus unseren bereits
genannten anträgen zugestimmt
könnten die bürger schon längst
entlastet sein der deutsche steuerzahler
sollte sich in zukunft entscheiden ob er
sich von diesen regierungen noch den
letzten euro aus der tasche ziehen
lassen will oder durch uns von der af
die ihnen mehr geld im portemonnaie hat
und wirklich spürbar entlastet wird
naja
zur wahrheit gehört auch dass
finanzminister lindner überhaupt kein
interesse daran hat den deutschen
steuerzahler zu entlasten
durch die extrem hohen energiekosten hat
er in den letzten monaten milliarden von
steuermehreinnahmen zu verbuchen gehabt
vorgestern wurde von gazprom die
gaslieferungen an bulgarien und polen
eingestellt heute vormittag hat sich die
mehrheit dieses haus ist dafür
entschieden auch schwere waffen an die
ukraine zu liefern es ist nur eine frage
der zeit bis auch bei uns die gas
lieferungen eingestellt werden und da
frage ich mich wie gedenkt in unsere
regierung in einem solchen fall die
bevölkerung mit energie und wärme
kurzfristig zu versorgen von dem
energiebedarf der deutschen wirtschaft
wollen wir an dieser stelle gar nicht
erst sprechen wäre es nicht doch besser
gewesen die kohle und atomkraftwerke
zumindest so lange am leben zu erhalten
bis wir eine gewisse energie autarkie
besitzen oder sollen wir jetzt jeden tag
2000 tiefer aus amerika mit
umweltschädlichen fracking gas die
deutsche wirtschaft am laufen gehalten
meine damen und herren mit dieser
olivgrünen kriegs und katastrophen
politik müsste nun auch dem letzten
aufgefallen sein dass sich mit
erneuerbaren energien in deutschland
eben nicht autark versorgen lässt
kohle und atomenergie wird in
deutschland noch jahre benötigt sichert
arbeitsplätze und wohlstand für die
mittelschicht und die bürger eben auch
im ländlichen raum
das gemüse bei den basken ist normal
keiner aus deswegen habe sollten sie
nicht bei antidemokraten in katar nach
gas betteln sondern die heimischen
energiequellen die kohle und atomenergie
die eben sauber und günstig seit jahren
verfügbar ist die sie seit jahrzehnten
kaputtmachen stärken und sichern
[Gelächter]
politik heißt nicht frieren gegen putin
sondern das aus für die deutsche
wirtschaft und atomstrom noch als
letzter satz ist die zukunft für
deutschland mit den neuen reaktoren
haben wir die möglichkeit wieder eine
marktführerschaft zu erreichen einen
energiesicherheit in deutschland zu
erreichen vielen dank
gärtner war das für die afg fraktion
noch einmal auf den von mir soeben
erteilten ordnungsruf zurück es ist an
dieser stelle mehrfach deutlich gemacht
worden dass das fotografieren in der
sitzung und aus der laufenden sitzung
heraus untersagt ist frau von storch sie
haben während der rede eines kollegen
fotografiert und damit gegen die
genannte maßgabe verstoßen richtig ist
dass sie dieses foto offensichtlich
nicht in den sozialen medien gepostet
haben darauf kommt es aber nicht an
und damit bleibt der ordnungsruf so
erhalten wir fahren in der aktuellen
stunde fort so bundestags
vizepräsidentin petra pau hat hier das
noch mal erläutert hier stellt sich der
bundestag natürlich auch auf die vielen
smartphones ein auch etwas was es erst
seit ein paar jahren natürlich hier gibt
und herren wir diskutieren dieses thema
heute nicht im luftleeren raum sondern
wir diskutieren ist in einer sehr sehr
fragilen situation in der wir uns
befinden der gaslieferstopp putins nach
polen und bulgarien macht deutlich um
was es gerade geht es geht darum dass
energiepreise das gas lieferungen von
putin als waffe genutzt werden es geht
darum dass menschen zutiefst
verunsichert werden sollen und dass
gesellschaften gestaltet werden sollen
und ich sage ihnen es wird putin nicht
gelingen und wissen sie warum weil als
ampel dafür sorgen werden dass wir diese
gesellschaft zusammenhalten weil wir die
maßnahmen ergreifen die jetzt notwendig
sind und das gilt für die gesamte breite
der wirtschaft und der gesellschaft für
gross importeure zwischenhändler für
unternehmen metallindustrie
chemieindustrie für jeden einzelnen
menschen und natürlich gerade auch für
jeden menschen mit wenig geld
ich möchte ich möchte konkret werden um
es einmal deutlich zu machen wie weit
wir auch dem weg schon vorangekommen
sind und weil wir gerade eine so was von
rückwärtsgewandte rede gehört haben dass
das was wir gerade erleben ist
preissprünge wegen fossilen energien
wegen der abhängigkeit und wegen der
vielen inflation die wir haben und
robert habeck hat es gestern wunderbar
bei twitter in seinem video erläutert
werde ärztlich gesät hat gesehen hat
schauen sie sich zahn ist sehenswert wir
gehen stück für stück gehen wir raus aus
diesen fossilen energien gehen wir raus
aus der abhängigkeit und machen die
sicherheit für die zukunft auch für die
menschen was die preise angeht immer
realer und immer greifbar wir werden sie
nicht die möglichkeit geben uns zu
treiben wir entscheiden wann wir handeln
wir geben den takt vor wir entscheiden
was passiert wir bereiten uns vor für
den schlimmsten fall aber was wir auch
machen ist dass wir schritt für schritt
das tun was verantwortlich ist und dafür
auch sorgen dass die sicherheit bei der
energieversorgung in deutschland besteht
ich bin ihnen dankbar liebe union dass
sie dieses thema heute aufgesetzt haben
weil sie es aufsetzen in einem moment an
dem genau einen tag vorher das kabinett
alle infos alle punkte beschlossen hat
im aus dem zweiten entlastungspaket
nicht will sie ihnen noch einmal
aufzählen falls sie da was verpasst
haben der grundfreibetrag wird angehoben
die eeg-umlage wird abgeschafft es gibt
300 euro energiepreis pauschale für alle
angestellten und selbstständigen
270 euro heizkostenzuschuss 200 euro für
die menschen in der grundsicherung 100
euro einmalzahlung für die arbeit für
menschen im arbeitslosengeld 1 100 euro
für alle kinder und jugendlichen über
das kindergeld und dauerhaft künftig 20
euro pro monat sofort zuschlag für die
kinder und ich sage ihnen eines herrscht
einiger weil sie gesagt haben es muss
jetzt komm ich hatte gestern abend
gestern abend hatte ich die letzte ampel
runde dazu und das ja das ist wichtig
das sage ich ihnen bei daran hängt die
umsetzung und nichts war stärker im raum
als der will das jetzt schnell auf die
straße zu bekommen und genau das werden
wir tun sie werden sie es wird kommen
und dann wird das da draußen dürfen
entscheiden
wir wissen dass die auseinandersetzungen
der wir sind keine keine ist die jetzt
schnell zu ende geht sondern wir werden
mit dieser auseinandersetzung leben und
arbeiten müssen für eine ganze weile
deswegen planen wir deswegen gehen wir
voran und deswegen haben wir eine
energie geld auf den weg gebracht das
jetzt gerade ausbuchstabiert wird dass
wir in zukunft ein instrument haben
werden mit dem wir sehr schnell menschen
die es nötig haben direkt geld zu lassen
kommen egal ob selbst selbständig oder
angestellt oder ein kind im kita alltag
all diese menschen sollen direkt konkret
geld bekommen und ich sage ihnen jetzt 1
wir haben das in verschiedensten
situationen hier gehabt die gießkannen
politik die sie immer wieder vorschlagen
das ist das was nicht funktioniert was
nicht finanziertes wo ihre haushälter
ihnen reinschreiben das alles unter
haushaltsvorbehalt steht sie reden wir
machen dass es der unterschied und dass
es die politik der ampel
zum schluss eine grundsätzliche
bemerkungen
fast alle in diesem haus und ich sage
gerade mit blick auf den redner vor mir
fast alle in diesem haus dürften am
letzten sonntag froh gewesen sein dass
in frankreich emanuel makro präsident
geworden ist und nicht die
rechtsextremen marine le pen es ist es
ist noch einmal gut gegangen und das
liegt auch darin weil sehr viele
menschen trotz der wut die sie hatten
sich entschieden haben für makro
zustimmen und diesen menschen müssen wir
sehr dankbar sein und sie haben das
getan auch wenn sie wenig geld hatten
auch wenn sie sorgen hat noch wenn sie
probleme hatten sind sie der
rechtsextremen propaganda nicht auf den
leim gegangen das heißt aber für uns die
lehre muss sein gerade in krisen gerade
wenn spaltungen im raum steht gerade
wenn putin sich in unsere gesellschaften
versucht einzumischen dürfen wir keinen
zurücklassen wir dürfen es nicht
zulassen dass unsere gesellschaft
gestaltet wird das ist eine aufgabe von
sehr fundamentaler größenordnung und
genau das ist das was wir als ampel tun
werden wir werden niemanden zurücklassen
das ist politik der ampel die wir
gemeinsam umsetzen vielen dank vielen
dank herr kollege
andreas fritsch war das bündnis 90/die
grünen und hat es ja auch angekündigt
auch auf der tagesordnung steht zum
beispiel der die einmalzahlung oder auch
die anpassung der eeg umlage auch das
finde ich hier noch übertragen christian
laie spricht jetzt für die linksfraktion
sehr geehrter herr präsident meine damen
und herren die energiepreise gehen durch
die decke allein heizöl und kraftstoffe
sind um 63 prozent teurer geworden die
jährlichen energiekosten für einen
familien musterhaushalt sind im märz um
80 prozent gestiegen das sind
3200 euro obendrauf können sie sich
vorstellen was
3200 euro für einen musterhaushalt
bedeuten denn eines kann ich ihnen sagen
der musterhaushalt verdient nicht so gut
wie weg hier meine damen und herren und
deswegen hatten schon im februar 80
prozent der menschen da draußen angst
vor der nächsten heizkostenabrechnung
und daher sage ich ihnen der bundestag
darf den sozialen sprengstoff nicht
unterschätzen der in den energiepreisen
liegt das konzept die mittelschicht und
die kleinen leute zahlen und oben
knallen die sektkorken wird in dieser
krise nicht funktionieren wir brauchen
jetzt eine zeitenwende für mehr soziale
gerechtigkeit meine damen und herren
und was machen eigentlich andere staaten
gegen die hohen energiepreise in der
sonst so wirtschaftsliberalen schweiz
gibt es seit jahrzehnten des amtes
preisüberwacher der im extremfall
preisvorgaben per verordnung durchsetzen
kann in italien kontrolliert die
finanzpolizei strom öl und gas und zwar
vom einkauf über die produktion bis zum
verkauf und warum damit spekulanten
keine kasse machen können und in
frankreich reguliert der staat die
strompreise die französische regierung
hat beim staatlichen stromkonzern die
energiepreise bei vier prozent die
deckel zum vergleich bei uns stiegen in
der gleichen zeit die strompreise um 23%
4% zu 23 prozent das merken sie jetzt
selber oder sowas tut unsere politik
gegen die steigenden preise ein
hochbezahlter ein hochbezahlter ex
politiker gab die parole aus frieren für
die freiheit und eins sage ich ihnen er
wird nicht frieren wenn die preise
weiter steigen minister habe gab
energiespartipps und kommentierte das
schont den geldbeutel und ärgert putin
und das bundeskartellamt schießt den
vogel ab und dreht wegen monopol preisen
auf autobahn tankstellen dazu zum tanken
von der autobahn runter zu fahren
heidewitzka
vielleicht wäre es die aufgabe des
kartellamtes gewesen monopol preise zu
verhindern anstatt solche geheimtipps
auszuarbeiten oder es ist ja wie ein
witz woanders reguliert die politik die
energiepreise und bei uns werden
energiespartipps und durchhalteparolen
von gut bezahlten politikern an weniger
gut bezahlte haushalte durch gegeben und
wir sagen daher das problem muss bei der
wurzel gepackt werden und der staat ist
jetzt gefordert mondpreise bei der
energie so weit wie es geht zu
verhindern und das fängt damit an
dass strompreise eben auch an der börse
gebildet werden und an der börse gibt es
das merit order prinzip und wie
funktioniert das das teuerste
gaskraftwerk gibt den preis vor für alle
anderen kraftwerke das teuerste
kraftwerk gibt den preis vor für alle
anderen billigeren kraftwerke und das
mitten in einer energiepreis krise was
ist denn das für ein wahnsinn außer für
die kraftwerksbetreiber für die es
gerade party meine damen und herren
von der freie markt er regelt das nicht
und deswegen sagen wir es braucht eine
staatliche
preiskontrolle und das geht wenn man
will denn das gibt es in deutschland
schon und zwar beim netzentgelt da
funktioniert der markt auch nicht und
deswegen kontrolliert der staat die
preise und wie macht er das er lässt
sich die betriebskosten auf den tisch
legen dann wird eine profit marge
festgesetzt die natürlich nicht durch
die decke geht und so werden mondpreise
verhindert und wenn wir das instrument
hier schon haben warum wird das denn
dann nicht angewandt und wir sagen
deckeln sie die energiepreise jetzt das
wäre vernünftig und gerecht
und ich höre hier den hörer hier den
widerspruch ich denke mal das liegt
daran dass sich das wie eine halbe
verstaatlichung anfühlt weil es ja auch
eine halbe verstaatlichung ist aber das
ist in ordnung das ist okay so wenn wir
merken doch gerade wir merken doch
gerade die dasein
energieversorgung ist daseinsvorsorge
und wir merken doch gerade wir merken
doch gerade diese ali sierung der
energiemärkte das war ein fehler das ist
wie krankenhäuser das ist liberalisiert
man einfach nicht und wir merken doch
gerade wenn die bevölkerung für die top
profite von einigen wenigen die
stromrechnung zahlt dann ist das einfach
falsch und deswegen sagen wir ihnen in
der krise des kapitalismus hilft nicht
noch mehr mag dann braucht es eine
regierung die sich mutig vor ihre
bürgerinnen und bürger stellt und sich
mit den konzernen angeht so geht
gerechtigkeit in der krise danke schön
christian anleihe rades für die
linksfraktion und nun gibt es auch einen
redner aus der
bundesratsbank der minister für
wirtschaft und energie aus nordrhein
westfalen ist hier andreas pinkwart soll
nun als nächstes sprechen
und energie des landes
nordrhein-westfalen professor andreas
pinkwart
herr präsident meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren wir
diskutieren heute in der aktuellen
stunde des deutschen bundestags die
energiepreisentwicklung
vor dem hintergrund außergewöhnlicher
schwierige herausforderung für unser
energiesystem in unserem land und wir
wissen dass durch den schrecklichen
krieg in der ukraine unser energiesystem
noch nie so stark herausgefordert war
wie im moment und deswegen muss eine
debatte in aktuellen stunde zu
energiepreisen sich natürlich einerseits
damit beschäftigen wie können wir
insbesondere die einkommensschwächeren
haushalten
wie können wir insbesondere die
energieintensiven unternehmen in dieser
schwierigen situation entlasten das tut
die bundesregierung hat unterschiedliche
paket auf den weg gebracht der bundesrat
hatte darum gebeten wir sehen viele
wichtige schritte durch die
bundesregierung auf weg gebracht
bearbeitet sie werden heute nachmittag
dankenswerterweise auch mit der
wirtschaftsministerkonferenz jetzt über
die energieintensiven unternehmen
betreffenden maßnahmen sprechen dafür
sind wir dankbar hier ist vieles auf den
weg wie es jetzt kurzfristig hilft
haushalte und unternehmen zu entlassen
ist dringend notwendig und hier arbeiten
eng zusammen meine damen und herren wir
müssen uns in dieser situation aber doch
auch fragen wo auch ein gas embargo
drohen könnte schneller als wir das
vielleicht bislang befürchtet hatten und
voraussehen konnten dass wir uns mit
blick auf die energiepreise fragen
müssen wie gehen wir mit dem energie
angebot um wie gehen wir mit der
nachfrage und wie können wir das so
gestalten dass die energiepreise in
dieser notsituation nicht noch
dramatisch ansteigen denn dagegen könnte
der staat mit allen mitteln die wir
mobilisieren könnte gar nicht
gegenhalten wir müssen uns also fragen
wie können wir die energiequellen
schneller diversifizieren wie können wir
neue quellen erschließen wie können wir
auch den fußweg jetzt in dieser
situation von gas zu kohle zu schwere zu
anderen instrumenten beschleunigen
gerade für die energieintensiven
unternehmen meine damen und herren
hier spielräume wir müssen allerdings
auch die genehmigungsverfahren anpassen
auch hier bieten wir die bundesregierung
um unterstützung wenn jetzt das embargo
käme muss die industrie trotzdem so weit
es geht weiter arbeiten können hier
müssen wir innovativ werden hier müssen
wir schnell sehen dass das angepasst
werden darauf müssen wir uns
konzentrieren und alles das entscheiden
dass wir eben auch die brücke zum
klimaneutralen ufer verkürzen und gas
durch andere stützpfeiler auf dem weg
dorthin ersetzen dafür brauchen wir
andere konventionelle energien von denen
wir glaubten dass wir uns schon längst
hätten von verabschieden können
möglicherweise werden wir die kurz
mittelfristig stärker einsetzen müssen
das gilt aus meiner sicht für alle
konventionellen energien bis ende der
20er jahre ich möchte nur für die
nordrhein westfälische landesregierung
auch hier bekräftigen wir wollen
möglichst 2030 abschließend aus der
kohle aussteigen aber bis dahin brauchen
wir eine brücke hin zum anderen
klimaneutralen ufer die auch tragfähig
ist dann müssen wir alles in den blick
nehmen und wir brauchen neue
stützpfeiler mit erneuerbaren die
schneller zugebaut werden das müssen wir
beschleunigen und hier unterstützen wir
das von herrn herberg vorgelegte paket
wenn wir die nutzung erneuerbarer
energien endlich in ein überragendes
öffentliches interesse stellen können
werden wir es einfacher haben planungs
und genehmigungsverfahren in unserem
land durchzusetzen und auch und das füge
ich hinzu aus nordrhein- westfälischer
sicht auch endlich die netze auszubauen
denn bislang ist der offshore wind in
nordrhein westfalen erst ab frühestens
2030 verfügbar und das muss meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren auch deutlich
beschleunigt werden hier setzen wir auf
mutige entscheidungen der
bundesregierung
oder mit erneuerbare ausbau auch ganz
lebenspraktisch schneller vorankommt
brauchen wir mehr standardisierung mit
digitalisierung mehr manpower in den
genehmigungsbehörden wir brauchen noch
viel mehr fachkräfte im land bundesweit
werden
140.000 mitarbeiter und mitarbeiter im
handwerk benötigt um die energiewende
hin zu den erneuerern möglich zu machen
hier gilt es endlich die berufliche
qualifizierung die tätigkeit im handwerk
in anderen bereichen wieder anpacken in
unserer gesellschaft damit mehr junge
leute dorthin geht für mich sind
handwerkerinnen und handwerker die klima
macher unserer zeit dafür müssen wir
werben meine damen und damit ihre
doktoranden
und und das sehen wir neben der
verteuerung der energiepreise
dass auch die materialpreise galoppieren
und das handwerk und alle anderen
bereiche massiv darunter leiden dass sie
das material nicht haben um diese
energiewende vorantreiben zu können dies
könnte sich meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren noch
verschärfen wenn die energieintensiven
unternehmen in deutschland nicht mehr
die energie verfügbar haben um in der
grundstoffindustrie und in anderen
industrien ihre beiträge zu leisten wenn
wir das auch noch alles importieren
wollten würden wir uns im übrigen ein
neues klumpenrisiko abhängigkeit zu
legen und wir wären nicht mehr so
leistungsfähig und die preise würden
explodieren
deswegen möchte ich hier noch einmal für
die nordrhein westfälische industrie
sagen und das sage ich auch für die
sozialpartner die sich hier am
vergangenen wochenende auch noch einmal
ganz deutlich zu wort gemeldet haben mit
blick auf ein energie anlage und da sind
wir auch der bundesregierung sind für
den energie lässt auch sehr dankbar dass
sie alles andere als selbstverständlich
sich dann hier auch in die brandung zu
stellen aber wir sagen man sehr
verehrten damen und herren ein energie
embargo aus deutscher sicht zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt hieß dass wir stärker uns
belasten würden als den aggressor dass
wir uns die möglichkeiten auch nehmen
würden all diese umbaumaßnahmen in der
notwendigen weise voran zu bringen das
würde unserem standort schalen für den
klima schaden deswegen wollen alles
unternehmen um die abhängigkeit vom gas
vom öl von kohle weiter zu reduzieren
bevor wir eine solche entscheidung
treffen meine sehr verehrten damen und
wir müssen jetzt auch darauf achten dass
eine arbeit die bundesnetzagentur auch
dafür sind wir dankbar tag und nacht
sich vorzubereiten es könnte sein
dass ein solches embargo ein solcher
ausfall der gaslieferungen auch in den
nächsten wochen und trotzdem bevorstehen
könnte das würde zu ganz erheblichen
fraktionen führen und deswegen muss man
sich klug darauf vorbereiten wir müssen
uns eng abstimmen
und wir müssen sehen dass wir uns nicht
die brückenpfeiler
die wir brauchen selbst weg schlagen
wenn wir das nicht gut organisiert
bekommen denn wir brauchen meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren eine
gesicherte versorgung eine starke
industrie um jetzt voran zu kommen beim
umbau unseres energiesystems und unserer
industrie mit vereinfachten planungs und
genehmigungsverfahren mit mehr
bereitschaft in dieser bereiche zu
investieren um dann auch den vorteil der
erneuerbaren energien endlich für unser
land auch nutzen zu können denn wände
sie konsequent ausbauen wenn wir sie
auch mit einer entsprechenden
wasserstoffwirtschaft verbinden dann
schaffen wir es auch die energiepreise
langfristig wieder stabilisieren zu
können dafür brauchen die technologie
innovation und investition das gilt es
jetzt klug voranzutragen meine sehr
verehrten damen und sein
hier möchte ich nur mal ändern beispiel
sagen bei dem erneuerbaren ausbauen weil
ja da auch mal schon mal die frage ist
ja wer ist denn da wie weit gekommen
und dann möchte ich hier dringend davor
warnen dass wir uns allgemeinen
illusionen hingeben wir hätten das spiel
schon halb erreicht
sondern wir stehen leider erst am anfang
gemessen an unseren sehr ehrgeizig
ziehen ich will dass nur in wenigen
beispielen sagen wir haben nordrhein
westfalen sei 2016 photovoltaik
anbauverfahren können ausbau jährlichen
ausbau wunderbar wollen wir jetzt aber
nochmal verdrei bis vervierfacht
dies nach ja
unter dem wind ausbau sind 4000 vertrag
- kilometer kleiner als baden
württemberg auch ein wichtiges
industrieland nordrhein westfalen
nordrhein westfalen hat eine dichtere
wohnbevölkerung weil es mehr einwohner
hat trotzdem haben wir drei mal zu viel
wind zugebaut den letzten vier jahren
die baden württemberg und bei den
genehmigungen die uns vorliegen bei den
genehmigungen für die nächsten jahre
haben wir achten mal mehr genehmigt so
dass baden württemberg oder muss ich
natürlich auch sagen meine damen und
herren wenn wir das alles erst mal dann
müssen jetzt auch alle mitmachen und
dann müssen sie sich auch für ihre
bürgerinnen und bürger stellen und auf
die notwendigkeit dieser ausbaumaßnahmen
hinweisen sich hinter diese maßnahmen
stellen bund und länder und aus dem wald
energie minister nicht allzu schwer
machen dass die ziele erreicht werden
können wenn wir sie nicht erreichen
werden die wir ganz andere debatten über
energiepreissteigerungen zukunft haben
das sollten wir vermeiden hier gilt es
jetzt sie aber auf zu kämpfen und alle
müssen ihre verantwortung aber auch
übernimmt hat sie dankte
der minister für wirtschaft und energie
aus nordrhein-westfalen noch in gut zwei
wochen werden die karten wieder neu
gemischt dann sind landtagswahlen
nächster redner ist jens spahn ehemalige
gesundheitsminister sitzt aber
mittlerweile im ausschuss unter anderem
im ausschuss für wirtschaft
der kollegien spart sie die situation
herr präsident lieber kollege und
kollegen vielen dank herr minister
pinkwart dass sie noch einmal deutlich
gemacht haben wo die cdu regiert da geht
es mit dem ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien voran vielen dank vielen dank
dafür
zu der aktuellen debatte und zum titel
der debatte wir hätten uns übrigens eine
politischere titel gewünscht aber das
ist leider mit den titeln dieser
aktuellen stunde immer so dass die
neutral sein sollen also unser titel wer
gewesen kehrtwende der bundesregierung
zu spät zu wenig zu bürokratisch alles
drin in dtl wer trifft ist dann ziemlich
genau
und ich will zum zu spät was sagen wir
haben hier auf antrag der union am 18
februar am 17 märz bereits debatten zu
den energiepreisen gehabt und ich habe
sie noch im ohr die kollegen morgens
grimmels outreach sie machen zum teil
das wogegen sie vor zwei monaten noch
gesprochen haben und ich empfehle ihnen
der kollege gremmels wenn sie gleich
wieder lautstarke reden denken sie dran
sind könnten ihre worte in vier sechs
wochen wieder essen müssen weil sie am
ende doch tun was richtig ist und was
wir hier vorschlag
nun erkennen sie endlich an nachdem sie
es vor zwei monaten nicht anerkannt
haben dass es ein problem gibt bei den
energiepreisen und sie tun ja sie tun
was immer hin dass eine kehrtwende
aber eben zu spät zu wenig zu
bürokratisch zu spät ist dann am ende
eben auch ein problem vor allem für die
bürgerinnen und bürger seit vielen
wochen und monaten überlegen sich band
da diejenigen die heizen handwerk und
mittelstand wie sie am ende die
tankfüllung das heizen noch bezahlen
können und jede woche später die die
notwendigen entscheidungen getroffen
werden ist für diese bürgerinnen und
bürger für die breite mitte in der
bevölkerung eben eine woche zu spät an
hilfe in dieser schwierigen zeit bessing
tun sie ist endlich was wir schon seit
zwei monaten einfordern und beschließen
sie es hier im deutschen bundestag
es ist zu wenig in der breite und in der
tiefe rentner studenten handwerk und
mittelstand gehen leer aus viele
millionen menschen lassen sie mit den
steigenden energiekosten allein und ja
es ist richtig dass sie bei den
geringverdienern die gerade von ihnen
angekündigten dinge tun das ist gut aber
es sind mittlerweile die normalverdiener
auch die breite mitte in deutschland die
von diesen starken energiepreisen
betroffen ist und zu viele davon
erreichen sie mit ihren maßnahmen nicht
und das ist eben ein problem das ist zu
wenig liebe kolleginnen und kollegen von
der ampel und
ist übrigens deswegen auch zu wenig und
auch zu wenig in der summe selbst die
300 euro pauschale kommen ja weil sie
die noch besteuert als 300 euro bei
niemann muss man ja mal dazu sagen wenn
sie das hier immer so raus stellen es
ist deswegen zu wenig in der breite und
in der tiefe weil sie nicht das problem
in den punkt stellen die hohen
energiepreise sondern weil sie in der
binnen logik einer ampel koalition am
ende versuchte mein paket zu schnüren wo
jeder irgendwie seine spielwiese hat
wenn sie wirklich die gesellschaft
zusammenhalten wollen dann machen sie
das was richtig ist und nicht das was
sich aus der binnen logik einer
ampelkoalition ergibt weil jeder ein
bisschen was denn dann auch haben muss
dadurch ist es eben auch zu bürokratisch
geworden der kollege steine jahr schon
darauf hingewiesen über eine milliarde
euro bürokratiekosten bei den 300 euro
pauschale über eine milliarde euro wir
haben heute morgen über ein
belastungsmoratorium für bürokratie
diskutiert gerade auch bei den
arbeitgebern bedeutet das zusätzlichen
aufwand wenn das über den lohn mit
ausgezahlt werden soll das ist genau das
was wir heute morgen gemeint haben in
dieser schwierigen zeit es ist eben das
falsche die wirtschaft handwerk
mittelstand vor allem die kleinen
unternehmen mit zusätzlicher bürokratie
auch für ihre pauschale zu belegen sie
zusätzlich zu belasten deswegen genau
damit so etwas nicht mehr passiert
brauchen wir dieses bürokratie
moratorium liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
da ist die frage was denn stattdessen
kennen sagen was stattdessen eine
entlastung über steuern über die steuern
auf die energie das wäre der richtige
weg gewesen das wäre schnell gegangen
streiche 19 sätze 7 etwa bei der
mehrwertsteuer den gesetzentwurf hätte
ich ihnen noch schreiben können und ihn
hätten wir in einer woche hier
beschließen könne neben deutschen
bundestag wenn wir gewollt hätten der
weg über die steuern wäre einfach
gewesen ist werde schnell gegangen und
es hätte vor allem alle erreicht und
deswegen bitten wir sie inständig im
interesse der bürgerinnen und bürger von
handwerk und mittelstand gehen sie weg
von ihrem paket mit den
unterschiedlichsten bürokratischen
maßnahmen die am ende bei vielen gar
nicht ankommen und gehen sie den weg
über entlastung bei den energiesteuern
denn sie kommt bei allen an die gerade
betroffen sind
und ein letztes
planbarkeit und bezahlbarkeit das sind
zwei seiten einer medaille
und da sehen wir übrigens gerade jetzt
auch mit der situation polen bulgarien
der stopp der lieferungen von gas führt
zu unsicherheit an den gasmärkten und zu
steigenden preisen und das tut es unter
anderem deswegen weil es keinen plan
gibt den fordern wir auch seit monaten
ein ich finde das gut mit insta das ist
die kür ich freue mich auch wenn die
kommunikation da gelingt ich wirklich
nur gelegentlich freuen wenn auch die
pflicht mit dabei wäre nämlich dass dem
deutschen bundestag diesen parlament ein
konzept vorgelegt wird haben sie
übrigens heute morgen beschlossen dem
antrag einen ausstiegsfahrplan aus der
russischen abhängigkeit fordern wir seit
zwei monaten ein und wenn es diesen
fahrplan gebe dann könnten sich auch
alle marktteilnehmer darauf einstellen
und jede kleine verunsicherung um sie
durch neuigkeiten würde nicht zu
steigenden preisen führen das ist der
entscheidende teil also legen wir
endlich diesen ausstiegsfahrplan vor
auch das beruhigt die preise
vielen dank herr kollege sparen nächster
redner ist der bereits angesprochene
kollege timo und gremmels spd frei zu
und timon gremmels sitz im ausschuss für
klimaschutz und energie
herr präsident meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren ich das irgendwann mal
sagen würde ersparen werden doch lieber
beim gesundheits thema geblieben da
hatten sie mehr kompetenz als bei denen
überlegen wir noch mal ob ich diesen
satz nicht zurücknehme aber
ich bin echt sprachlos und vor allem
wenn man ihren forderungen hier gefolgt
hätte ersparen dann erinnere ich nur
daran haben gesagt wir sollten wir öfter
auf die cdu die ihr
fraktionsvorsitzender merz hat am 10
gefordert die gaslieferung von über 91
sofort einzustellen was hätte denn das
für die auswirkungen auf die
energiepreise gehabt das was sie hier
machen ist noch ein doppel zügige spiel
sich hierhin zu stellen sie fordern
dinge die die energiepreise nach oben
getrieben hätten und andererseits
fordern sie hier im krieg die
preissenkungen das ist zynisch meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren und dann
fordern sie hier von der bundesregierung
ein die würde doch endlich handeln und
sie solle endlich was tun und soll einen
fahrplan erarbeiten die wir unabhängig
von fossilen energien werden herr spahn
sind sie denn mal in den
ausschusssitzungen was macht denn robert
habeck tagtäglich tag und nacht er macht
nicht andere als daran zu arbeiten und
übrigens die schubladen waren leer als
sie den bundeswirtschaftsminister
hier gestellt haben wo waren die
schubladen und wollen ihre konzepte
overland der fall der hätte auch schon
früher eintreten können es war doch
nichts da das muss jetzt diese regierung
erarbeiten 16 jahre hat die cdu die
kanzlerin gestellt und sie tun so als ob
es neben den letzten 16 jahren nichts zu
tun hätten meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren das ist unredlich das sage
ich ihnen an dieser stelle
und diese koalition handelt nicht erst
seit dem 24 februar sondern wir haben
vorher schon uns um steigende
energiepreise gekümmert weil das eine
fossile inflation ist die wir erleben
die verstärkt wurde durch den
angriffskrieg
russland auf die ukraine aber die vorher
schon da war unser erst lasst uns paket
insofern sind wir ja dankbar für die
aktuelle stunde weil man es nochmal
dagegen kann am 23
februar einen tag vor dem angriff
russlands da haben wir das erste
entlastungspaket als koalition auf den
weg gebracht ich erinnere man die punkte
abschaffung der eeg umlage zum ersten
juli was wir gleich beschließen werden
erhöhung der pendlerpauschale zum ersten
januar rückwirkend
heizkostenzuschuss für wohngeldempfänger
azubi studierende einmalzahlungen für
bedürftige sofort zuschlag von armut
betroffene kinder höhere
grundfreibeträge erhöhung der
werbungskostenpauschale erhöhung des
mindestlohns auf 12 euro verlängerung
des kurzarbeitergeldes steuerliche
entlastung für die wirtschaft
dann das zweite entlastungspaket vom 24
märz energie pauschale von 300 euro
einmal prinz von 100 euro zusätzlich für
jedes kind einmalzahlung von 100 eur für
empfängerin von sozialleistungen
zusätzlich zu dem bereits im februar
beschlossenen 100 euro absenkung von
energie steuern auf kraftstoffe nö
1-lauf flatrate das waren 15 konkrete
maßnahmen die die bürgerinnen und bürger
spürbar lasst meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren ja als dieses zu spät
erfahren was sie hier sozusagen herein
rufen wissen sie was zu spät ist nämlich
das was sie ausgebremst haben die
letzten 16 jahre waren nämlich die
energiewende hätten wir vorher den turbo
bei der energiewende beim ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien gezogen dann
hätten wir heute deutlich preiswertere
energiekosten weil die erneuerbaren
energien heute deutlich preiswerter sich
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
und deswegen das argumenten spät fällt
doch auf sich selber zurück ersparen sie
haben nicht gehandelt sie haben hier
gebremst und habe den ausbau verhindert
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
und ansonsten ja wir haben das jetzt
auch ein bisschen herr pinkwart gerade
gehört war ein bisschen wahlkampf nrw
ist okay aber ich meine wenn nun die
landesregierung von nrw sozusagen beim
ranking von 16 bundesländern sagt es
gibt aber noch ein bundesland was noch
schlechter ist als energie und daran
orientieren wir uns um das baden
württemberg freilich gesagt das würde
ich ein bisschen wenig und ich hätte mir
schon noch gewünscht herr pinkwart
nachdem sie hier auch ein haar weg
gelegt haben zurecht ich finde dass man
beim oster paket und ausbau der
windkraft noch mal nachlegen muss dass
sie vielleicht auch mal etwas gesagt
hätten zur ankündigung jahrhundert 1000
meter abstand für windkraftanlagen in
nrw zu kassieren habe ich leider
vermisst habe ich leider form ist meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren und sie
haben eben gerade auch nochmal
eingefordert vereinfachte
planungsverfahren für die umstellung für
die transformation richtung wasserstoff
bin ich sofort bei ihnen aber wenn wir
von vereinfachten planungsverfahren
sprechen da möchten wir auch
vereinfachte planungsverfahren für den
ausbau von windkraft nicht nur in nrw
sondern in ganz deutschland daran
arbeiten wir mit dem oster paket in
diesem sinne dieses land die menschen
sind mit dieser ampel koalition gut
aufgehoben und wir werden das
erfolgreich umsetzen in diesem sinne
alles gut und glückauf
vielen dank herr kollege chemnitz
wir sind hier alle in diesem haus
überrascht darüber dass hier auch
wahlkampfreden gehalten werden das ist
völlig ungewöhnlich
nächste rednerin ist die kollegin dr
ingrid nestle bündnis 90 die grünen
[Applaus]
herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
ich freue mich sehr dass die dass sie
von der cdu csu heute hier diese
aktuelle stunde einberufen haben das ist
ein sehr sehr wichtiges thema und ja es
ist auch sehr sehr wichtig dass wir über
die rolle der cdu/csu bei diesem thema
sprechen sie haben gesagt dass sie sich
große sorgen machen wegen der hohen
energiepreise und das teile ich das
teile ich zumindestens 100 prozent ich
könnte mir vorstelle ich mir noch
größere sorgen mache als sie weil ich
mir sehr genau angeschaut habe wo die
preise für die endkunden noch hingehen
werden das wird ja weiter steigen weil
die kosten zu hoch sind weil das gas das
wir jetzt ein speichern und im nächsten
winter an die endkunden verkaufen nicht
zu 70 prozent teurer als der
vergangenheit nicht doppelt so teuer
nicht dreifach so teuer eingekauft aus
dem ausland sondern sieben bis acht mal
so teuer
das ist der grund warum wir uns wirklich
sorgen machen und warum ist er ein ich
bin mit ihm in diesem punkt aber wir
müssen auch darüber reden wo endlich die
verantwortung liegt und das jetzt
versuchen es ist glaube ich die flucht
nach vorne er hatte sie in
wahlkampfzeiten versuchen möglichst laut
zu schreien situation ist übrigens
großer mist ja und zu hoffen dass dann
alle glauben wenn situation mist ist und
sie schreien dann muss wohl jemand
anderes sein ich glaube da haben sie im
kleinen denkt fehler gemacht zu 1000
es ist somit einen deutschen das
schlamassel ist die abhängigkeit von den
fossilen energien das schlamassel ist
dass wir weiter kaufen müssen weil sie
die energiewende verpennt haben weil sie
auf jahrelange hinweise dafür unabhängig
werden wollen mittendrin
einzudecken und den ausbau der
erneuerbaren durchgesetzt haben so geht
das nicht und jetzt schauen wir uns den
zweiten teil an nachdem er einmal auf
die sorgen die verantwortung geschaut
haben was ist denn mit ihrem
lösungsvorschlag
steuergeld ja es ist richtig wir haben
ja schon das zweite entlastungspaket
übrigens mit mehr milliarden hat sie
weil sie so stolz auf ihre 20 milliarden
hingewiesen haben sicherlich muss man
den menschen jetzt helfen aber sonst
habe ich nichts bei ihnen gehört kann
das das einzige sein nicht nur neue
waren energie nichts von
energieeffizienten nichts davon das
problem bei der wurzel zu packen und
tatsächlich rauszukommen aus dem
schlamassel wollen sie wirklich am dauer
einfach dieses problem mit steuergeld zu
retten das kann doch nicht ihr ernst
sein
team zwei tage
jeden zweiten tag fließt aus der eu
allein nach russland für gas eine
milliarde euro wollen sie einfach sagen
müssen also ich ganz viel steuergeld
bekommt dass es ihnen nicht mehr weh tut
das ist doch quatsch das ist doch gut
sich das kann doch nicht funktionieren
aber naja ich möchte auch einmal ein
paar worte an sie richten ich finde
nämlich dass auch ihre rede ziemlich an
der realität vorbeigehen sie haben gut
geforderten es war tatsächlich mutig
würde ich sagen mit ja doch doch relativ
dünner sachkenntnis so mag wie die
forderungen aufzustellen sie haben
gesagt naja war der netzentgelte ist
doch eine regulierung dann könnt ihr
einfach die restliche energie
preisregulierung fertig aus kein problem
mehr dass die dass die netzentgelte im
moment deutlich günstiger sind als der
strom an der börse liegt natürlich daran
dass tatsächlich die beschaffung dieser
netze deutlich günstiger ist als die
beschaffen von gas und kohle die wir
brauchen um strom zu produzieren
und da kann keine regulierung helfen ja
wenn das gas zum siebenfachen preis über
die grenze kommt dann können sie das
nicht weg regulieren und was ich
was ist besonders
was sie besonders schlimm fand ist dass
sie sich lustig machen über menschen die
energiespartipps geben dass sie sich
lustig machen über menschen die wege
aufzeigen solidarisch zu sein mit denen
die abhängig sind vom energieverbrauch
energieversorgung günstiger machen
sie wollen die energievorkommen
günstiger machen ja günstiger kann sie
werden wenn wir weniger verbrauchen
energie ist extrem knapp dass es klappt
alles klappt und deshalb ist es so teuer
ja natürlich können wir alle ja und
insbesondere die reichen sie tun mal
wieder soweit wir und energiespartipps
sich nun die anderen richten natürlich
können wir alle solidarisch sein und die
reichen verbrauchen viel mehr in den key
als die armen und ja natürlich wenn dir
alle dazu beitragen ich bin sicher dass
herr habe ich sehr viel mehr dazu
beiträgt als ziel weil er nämlich
verstanden hat um was es geht das ist
darum geht den energieverbrauch zu
reduzieren um die energiepreise wieder
runter zu bekommen weil gerade die leute
mit wenig geld in der tasche darauf
angewiesen sind bezahlbare energie zu
bekommen und ja da hilft auch mal eine
energiespartipps und ehrlich gesagt ich
glaube die menschen sind ziemlich
verletzt wenn sie auf sie hören wenn sie
sagen ach nee ich versucht gar nicht
erst mit weniger energie zurechtzukommen
und wenn sie dann im nächsten winter und
im nächsten sommer ihren abrechnungen
sehen werden ja und dann bei ihnen
anklopfen und sagen wo sie haben doch
gesagt ich solle nicht sparen aber ich
kann es nicht bezahlen sagen sie nein
das war alles lächerlich das ist nicht
lächerlich dass es die universität das
ist lösung eines leasing problems einen
riesigen schlamm als jetzt ich würde die
super gerne fragen wir anfangen zu
sparen und stünde aber machen sich gar
nicht
was wir machen müssen das ist an denn es
wurde mehrmals gesagt was minister habe
ich alleine mit seinem entschlossenen
handelns in der ganzen geschichte um
gazprom germania den entwurf man kosten
erspart hat das haben sie glaube ich mit
zehn reden ihren vorschlägen nicht
zusammen gesagt herzlichen dank leute
gehen
müssen wir
überlegen ließ regeln das doppeltop
komme ich zurück zur wahl die zeit für
die wahl ist abgelaufen eigentlich frage
dennoch ist noch ein mitglied des hauses
anwesen dass seine stimme noch
so und hier eilen doch einige
abgeordnete dann noch mal in die west
lobby worum geht es geht darum die
mitglieder des parlamentarischen
kontrollgremiums zu wählen mit namen
andré hahn von der linksfraktion
aufgestellt er hatte sich schon mal zur
wahl gestellt am 24 märz hat damals
nicht die erforderliche mehrheit von 369
stimmen bekommen sondern nur 341 jahr
stellen und so hat in die linksfraktion
jetzt heute noch einmal aufgestellt zu
erfahren
ja aber herr kollege buben sie wissen
ich muss den wahlgang schließen und wenn
ich sage wir schließen den wahlgang dann
können sie das nicht werden ihre ohne
reinschmeißen was sie ja vielleicht noch
ausgeführt haben also die ganz kleinen
moment beginnt
und sie wissen wie teuer das ist wenn
man das nicht macht nicht also
genau die abgeordneten bekommen
beziehungsweise müssen geld zahlen wenn
sie mir eine abstimmung nicht teilnehmen
bzw in wird was abgezogen aber natürlich
geht es ihnen hoffentlich hier eher um
den demokratischen
mit der ausbildung zu beginnen das
ergebnis der wahl wird ihnen später
bekannt gegeben wir kehren damit zurück
zur aktuellen stunde das nächste wort
erhält der kollegen manchmal
fdp-fraktion dem hansmann ist
entwicklungspolitische sprecher der
fdp-fraktion
präsident gesetzt die kolleginnen und
kollegen der brutale angriffskrieg
russlands auf die ukraine hat enorme
auswirkungen auf unsere
energieversorgung für alle bezahlbare
energiepreise sind aber die grundlage
für die lebensqualität und den wohlstand
nicht nur in deutschland sondern in ganz
europa aber in so einer debatte müssen
wir uns beginnen immer klar machen dass
gerade steigende energiepreise den
wohlstand im land ganz generell
betreffen der staat kann das mit
umverteilungs maßnahmen nicht wirklich
ausgleichen da kann es nur dämpfen und
zeitweise etwas verschieben und da
machen sie sich von der unionsfraktion
das muss ich ehrlich sagen ein bisschen
zu einfach aber es ist auch klar aufgabe
des staats dieses schocks befristet
abzumildern und insbesondere bei denen
zu helfen die den wohlstand im land
erwirtschaften und damit den staat
überhaupt erst finanzieren alte die
jeden tag mit ihrer arbeit die produkte
und dienstleistungen produzieren die
unser leben zu reich machen und damit
übrigens auch unser glücklicherweise
umfangreiche sozialsystem überhaupt erst
ermöglichen bevor wir zu den eigentlich
energiepreisen kommen erlauben sie mir
noch eine vorbemerkung die systematisch
wichtige und richtige maßnahme ist die
erhöhung der pendlerpauschale das
steuerrecht immer auch eingriffsrecht
ist ist das geradezu grund rechtlich
geboten es geht um das objektive
nettoprinzip im steuerrecht und deswegen
haben wir das auch gemacht aber weil wir
wissen dass gerade diese anpassung durch
die grundsätze der steuerverwaltung nur
sehr sehr langsam greifen haben wir auch
eine reihe von anderen zielgerichteten
maßnahmen beschlossen die schnell wirken
wie zum beispiel die absenkung der eeg
umlage auf 0 bereits im juli dieses
jahres deutschland hat die höchsten
strompreise in europa damit sinken mit
den strompreis um über 10 prozent ein
entlastungsvolumen von 6,6 milliarden
euro zusätzlich sollen alle
einkommensteuerpflichtigen
erwerbstätigen einen einmaligen zuschuss
von 300 euro als energiepreis pauschale
bekommen es wird kritisiert herr kollege
sparen dass diese pauschale der
einkommensteuer unterworfen wird aber
genau das sorgt steuersystematisch dafür
dass diese entlastung entsprechender
progression auch sozial gerecht wird man
könnte auf einen niedrigeren preis
nehmen und gleichmäßig verteilen das
wäre mit der gleichen fiskalischen
wirken aber es wäre sozial nicht so
gerecht
und wir wollen auch bereits zur
jahresmitte die steuerlast befristet auf
treibstoffe auf das europäische
mindestmaß absenken das macht diesel pro
liter 14 cent billiger benzin sogar um
30 cent und das entlastungs
entlastungsvolumen hier beträgt 3
milliarden euro dazu kommt die sehr
breit wirksamen erhöhung des
grundfreibetrags der familienzuschuss
heizkostenzuschuss und weitere maßnahmen
insgesamt bringt entlastungen von
ungefähr 16 milliarden euro auf den weg
und das ist doch genau das und das
richtige maß mitnehmen was der staat in
zu einer krise kurzfristig tun kann und
soll aber wir wissen auch dass es den
menschen zwar kurzfristig hilft deswegen
machen wir es auch aber die probleme die
im 3 stock ausgelöst haben löst das
nicht deswegen ist gleichzeitig sehr
wichtig dass wir die langfristige
perspektive nicht aus den augen
verlieren wir müssen unser land unseren
ganzen kontinent in den nächsten jahren
vor allem wirtschaftlich neu ausrichten
um künftig allgemeiner star abhängigkeit
von fossilen rohstoffen wegzukommen und
speziell aus der abhängigkeit von
problematischen lieferländern sowie
russland die energieerzeugung wird
künftig also wirtschaftlich wie auch
global strategischen klimapolitisch eine
zentrale rolle bekommen allein aus
nationalen nachhaltigen quellen wird das
nicht zu schaffen sein wir werden weiter
geht s ja große mengen energie
importieren müssen und künftig besser
vor solchen schocks geschützt zu sein
müssen diese lieferung aber nachhaltiger
und breiter differenziert werden daher
werden wir die deutsche die europäische
wirtschaft auch dabei unterstützen die
neuen technologien die im wesentlichen
schon entwickelt sind auf den global
umfasst den maßstab hochskalieren der
nötig ist es geht im wesentlichen um
stromerzeugung und als energieträger im
kern wasserstoff und daran hängen dann
viele andere technologien seines
ammoniakgase oder review als minister
pinkwart hat das auch schon erwähnt
damit helfen sie auch die immensen
herausforderungen die bei der
elektrischen energiespeichern haben
besser in den griff zu bekommen denn nur
so werden wir am ende bei den großen
ziel erfolgreich seinen treibhausgas
emissionen aus der weltwirtschaft zu
eliminieren bei der aktuellen energie
preiskrise sehen wir wie wichtig diese
fragen für uns sind damit in 20 oder 30
jahren keine bundesregierung ja ein
zeuge bündel von maßnahmen mehr spüren
muss weil man der letzten jahren vieles
verpasst hat wie wir es jetzt machen
müssen vielen dank
vielen dank an
die beteiligten forscher wurde der
kollegin dorothee bär cdu/csu-fraktion
lösen
sehr geehrter herr präsident und das ist
meine große freude dass die präsidieren
wo ich jetzt hier zu aktuellen stunde
von unserer fraktion hier sprechen darf
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen meine
sehr geehrten damen und herren es ist ja
ein ganz ganz vielen rednerinnen und
redner einer koalition heute
rübergekommen wie sie sich freuen dass
wir diese debatte aufgesetzt haben nur
hat man dann leider in den reden nicht
mehr so wahnsinnig viel davon gemerkt
weil es ein ziemliches rum gestöpselt
war trat auch von ihnen weiß es sich
jetzt schon zu wort melden zu erklären
was eigentlich zu der rote faden sein
soll der sich durch zieht durch die
entlastungen der bürgerinnen und bürger
und gerade heute an diesem tag wo die
meldung haben dass wir seit 1981 den
höchststand der inflation haben mit 7,4
prozent wäre es natürlich wesentlich
besser gewesen richtige entlassungen zu
machen als dieses gießkannenprinzip was
ich es dann angeblich beschlossen haben
das leben wird teurer in unserem land
das leben ist teuer gerade für
diejenigen die sich eben auch ansonsten
schon vor dieser inflation immer ganz
genau überlegen mussten wofür sie
eigentlich ihr geld ausgeben und das
betrifft ganz besonders auch die
familien in unserem land und da ist die
mutter die an der tür klingelt und sagt
kann ich mir backförmchen ausland ich
möchte nicht zu meiner mutter fahren die
in klammern drei kilometer weit weg
wohnt weil die spritkosten nicht mehr
leistbar sind da ist die mutter die sagt
wir backen heuer auch zu ostern nicht
mehr so viel weil die lebensmittelpreise
in die höhe geschossen sind das sind
diejenigen die ihre kinder nicht mehr so
oft zum sport fahren können weil es sich
nicht mehr leisten können und die ampel
geht dann einfach so drüber hinweg und
entlastet eben nicht die mitte der
gesellschaft entlastet nicht die
familien das sind nicht ihr entweder und
wenn da noch nicht so die
alleinerziehende ich sage ihnen ganz
offen diese koalition muss man sich
leisten können und für bürgerinnen und
bürger auf ihnen auch diejenigen die sie
gewählt haben bereut es jetzt zu tipps
was sie gewählt haben weil sie sagen wir
können uns unser leben nicht mehr
leisten sollen wir uns das nicht
vorgestellt
sie reden die ganze zeit vom aufbruch
überall auch block aufbruch auch wenn
man nur schaut nur wo ist denn dieser
aufbruch der klingt toll verkauft sich
gut aber diese aufbruch ist eben nicht
für alle das ist der haken an der sache
wenn man genau hinschaut nochmal
studentinnen und studenten rennen wir in
den trenton alleinerziehende schauen
alle in die röhre das heißt wir brauchen
eine entlastung und unterstützung
offensive wo der familie und unternehmen
aber auch eben rentnerinnen und rentner
auch in deutschland etwas haben und der
zur steinigung hatte angesprochen auch
unsere kommunen wie verzweifelt müssen
als bürgermeister sein wenn man sich
eben dann wenn uns wendet weil man sagt
wir brauchen da eben auch als
kommunalpolitiker
bringen diese unterstützung und deswegen
ist unser anspruch liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen als union dass wir uns für alle
einsetzen für alle bürgerinnen und
bürger in hessen haben
muss er schmunzeln aber macht es ja dann
auch hier so eine dynamik im parlament
fdp es ist ja auch ein bisschen peinlich
dass jetzt so ein bürokratiemonster
geschaffen haben hat ja auch maja herr
kohler lebens so merz gemerkt ja ich
habe eine große empathie spürt so was
dass sie wenn ihr nachher auch noch
sprechen kann dieser stelle
also da merkt man einfach ganz deutlich
dass sie wenn sie jetzt nicht mit in
dieser regierung gefangen werden ganz
anders handeln würden und dass es ihnen
wahnsinnig schwer fällt dafür die hand
geben zu müssen so
und wir sind auch der festen überzeugung
weil wir nämlich auch die
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer
vertreten in unseren parteien dass wir
sagen wir warme wohnung darf kein luxus
sein das wird aber wenn sie so
weitermachen die bundesministerin sagt
ja wir brauchen jetzt mal locker 400.000
neue wohnungen da bin ich mal gespannt
wie die umsetzung dabei ausschauen soll
sie versprechen sich lösen nicht die
probleme lösen nicht die lieferketten
probleme sie haben ein förder chaos was
sie jetzt machen wir haben
materialmangel wir haben explodierende
baukosten haben energiekosten die
steigen steigende zinsen der
zusammenbrechen der rohstoffversorgung
und und kein wort dazu heute sondern
einfach nur wir haben die gießkanne
löscht er auch mehrfach angesprochen
dass es angeblich keine wer aber selbst
herr kollege kam antritt der jetzt nicht
autos stellt auch nicht mehr da ist wir
freuen uns seiner rede auch noch mal das
potpourri der guten laune der
verschiedenen maßnahmen 100 gebetet hat
weil es einfach gar nicht möglich war
dass in einem satz zusammenzufassen also
unterm strich kann man sagen sie ist
nicht ehrlich zu den bürgerinnen und
bürgern in diesem land sie entlasten
nicht diejenigen die dringend darauf
gewartet haben die auch eine hoffnung
mit ihnen verbunden haben wir hoffnung
die sie jetzt bitter enttäuschen und
deswegen bin ich dankbar dass wir eine
so konstruktive eine so konstruktive
opposition zählt dass wir ihnen lösungen
auf den tisch legen wo die nichts
dagegen haben wenn sie die ganzen
kopieren weil wir das für die
bürgerinnen und bürger in unserem land
wollen bericht ist es sich danach weil
es nicht um uns geht sondern für alle da
draußen ganz herzlichen dank
vielen dank frau würde die bären
die zusätzliche robin mesa roche spd
fraktion
sehr geehrter präsident verehrte damen
und herren frau bär ich kenne die mutter
nicht wie bei ihm geklingelt hat aber
wenn sie in den letzten 16 jahren nicht
bei höheren löhnen niedrigeren mieten
und erneuerbaren energien ständig weg
gebremst hätten hätten sie ihr mehr
bieten können als mit akten
ich wollte meine rede beginnen mit dem
satz die energiepreise sind explodiert
alles wird immer teurer aber der satz
stimmt gar nicht was richtig ist energie
aus gas kohle und öl teurer und zwar
massiv was auch richtig ist wind und
solarenergie werden seit jahren
günstiger und zwar deutlich ich sage
also besser den satz die preise für
fossile energieträger sind explodiert
sie werden immer teurer aber viele
erneuerbare energien werden günstiger
dieser unterschied ist richtig für
millionen leute spielt dieser
unterschied allerdings erst mal keine
rolle sie leben zu mieten können sich
nicht aussuchen wie sie heizen da ist
ein ebene gasheizung verbaut oder sie
wohnen in einem alten haus und können
sich den umbau nicht leisten sie müssen
bezahlen für gas kohle oder öl ob sie
wollen oder nicht und deswegen müssen
sie jetzt deutlich mehr bezahlen als
noch vor ein paar monaten viele bringt
das finanziell an ihre grenzen viele
über ihre grenze ich verstehe völlig
sprachliche unterschiede sind da erst
mal zweitrangig welche energieträger
teurer sind aber politik muss beginnen
mit dem betrachten der wirklichkeit und
bei den energiepreisen ist die sache
klar gas kohle und öl werden teurer wind
und solar werden günstige politik muss
beginnt mit dem betrachten der
wirklichkeit während viren der
ampelkoalition die wirklichkeit
betrachten und an lösungen arbeiten
steht die cdu mit dem handy an der
tankstelle und beschimpfte über
benzinpreise der tankstellen über
benzinpreise zu schimpfen ist völlig in
ordnung das mag ich auch wie millionen
andere deutsche was nicht in ordnung ist
im videos in unsachlichen reden auf
instagram den eindruck zu erwecken man
könnte leicht die probleme lösen und es
läge nur an der regierung das geht nicht
wir müssen als erstes verstehen der
staat legt nicht fest wie teuer energie
es ersetzt nicht die preise fest wenn
die cdu wollte dass der staat die preise
bestimmt gelbes theoretisch zwei
möglichkeiten erstens der
stadtverordnete niedrigere preise und
entschädigt die energieunternehmen für
den verlorenen umsatz zweitens der staat
verstaatlicht die energieunternehmen
beide spd cdu überhaupt nicht sie müsste
es aber wollen wenn sie ernst meinte was
den wahlkämpfen gerade ständig anklingen
lässt von ihren großen ankündigung
bleibt bei ihren tatsächlichen
vorschlägen so wenig übrig sie können
sogar nicht erreichen was sie
wortgewaltig versprechen lassen sie uns
die sache deswegen ernsthaft betrachten
natürlich kann der staat preise in einem
gewissen rahmen beeinflussen und hier
wird es jetzt interessant wie sieht der
rahmen aus
kurzfristig kann der staat steuern
senken und er kann steuergeld einsetzen
genau das macht die bundesregierung wir
senken die eeg umlage auf 0 erhöhen die
plant händler pauschale wir bringen die
energiepreis pauschale diejenigen die es
besonders dringend brauchen bekommen
direkt geld in form von heizkosten
zuschüssen in form von einmalzahlungen
für kinder und in form von
einmalzahlungen alle die
sozialleistungen bekommen außerdem
entlasten wir uns in unternehmen bevor
die energiepreise ihre geschäftsmodelle
und später arbeitsplätze zerstören das
und noch viel mehr machen wir als
kurzfristige maßnahmen in dieser krise
reicht das nein das tut es nie aber es
macht es denen die es gerade besonders
schwer haben leichter diese
kurzfristigen maßnahmen sind richtig sie
helfen sie lösen das problem aber nicht
grundsätzlich und lassen sie mich
hinzufügen sie sind teuer daher werden
wir sie nicht ewig weiterführen können
gleichzeitig müssen wir davon ausgehen
dass die energieprobleme aber bleiben
wir brauchen also langfristige lösungen
darum werden wir die erneuerbaren
energien lassen sie mich sagen die
günstigen energien massiv und schneller
als jemals zuvor ausbauen dafür ändern
wir gerade die gesetze das hat zukunft
genauso dazu gehört wir erhöhen den
mindestlohn auf 12 euro und kämpfen für
flächen denken der tarifvertrag
tarifverträge damit endlich jeder
vollzeitjob finanzielle sicherheit
bietet in der kombination aus günstiger
nachhaltige energie und anständigen
löhnen werden wir alle erfolgreich sein
das ist der rote faden frau bär
das sind lösung die zeit brauchen werden
aber als anders als handy löw videos
sind die lösungen an die vielen dank
ordnen esa roche war das und damit
kommen wir zum letzten redner in dieser
aktuellen stunde aber wie gesagt das
thema energie wird hier noch in einigen
debatten heute behandelt werden letzter
redner bei uns jetzt hier ist lukas
kohler für die fdp-fraktion
und er ist stellvertretender
fraktionsvorsitzender
präsident meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren du ich glaube es ist übrigens
immer günstiger und ökologischer wenn
man seine förmchen bei der nachbarin
oder bei dem nachbarn leid wenn man dann
nicht mehr auto fahren muss aber das ist
so in seiner logik irgendwie die
zusammenhänge und ich freue mich auch
über empathie wir wir freuen uns dass
fdp sehr über empathie wir sind ja
selber sehr empathisch und auch immer
sehr offen gegenüber anderen menschen
ich habe da keine lacher gehört sonst
aber in dem fall hätte ich mir mit
denken noch nachhaltig mir noch viel
mehrere feuer weil mit denkt nämlich
bedeutet dass man verstehen dass das was
wir hier tun die vorbereitungen dafür
ist dass das was aus ökonomischer sicht
nämlich eine klima dividende einzuführen
oder einen klima geld einzuführen und
den menschen langfristig geld
zurückzugeben und zwar immer so dass wir
ökonomisch den sinnvollsten
effizientesten und besten weg gehen das
vorzubereiten das ist ganz klug das
kennt das deutsche steuerrecht noch
nicht es ist aber vor allen dingen
deswegen wichtig weil das ein prozess
der länger braucht und ja man am anfang
gibt es natürlich kosten und wir setzen
uns an den wärmsten stellen gegen
bürokratie ein das machen wir jetzt
heute gleich wenn wir darüber
diskutieren dass wir die eeg umlage
abschaffen wenn das ist nicht nur ein
immenser kosten senkt das ist auch ein
immenser bürokratie senken und das
machen wir an vielen vielen anderen
stellen auf das wir bürokratisch
nicht weiter machen wollen sondern ganz
klar bürokratie senken aber
lieber noch mal zurück an den anfang was
ist denn passiert vor etwa zweieinhalb
monaten hat dieser schreckliche krieg
begonnen zweieinhalb monate ist im
politischen berlin eine lange zeit herr
schwan habe ich das gefühl wenn man sich
immer vorstellt was wir hier getan haben
dass wir innerhalb dieser kurzen zeit
entlastungs paket o2 steht an der zeit
aufgebracht haben dass wir 30 milliarden
euro an die bürgerinnen und bürger
zurückgeben dass wir dafür sorgen dass
energiekosten reduziert werden dass wir
gleichzeitig darüber diskutieren die
eeg-umlage abzuschaffen dass wir über
erneuerbare energien und die
geschwindigkeit wie wir die ausbauen
über gasspeicher gesetze und über alle
diese anderen dinge nicht nur
diskutieren sie sind sie gerade manchmal
auch im eilverfahren umsetzen das zeigt
glaube ich wie handlungsfähig sind
aber sie haben sie haben ich finde sie
haben ganz interessanten punkt gemacht
herr sparen sie haben gesagt dass wir
jetzt einplanen bräuchten er hat das hat
mich überrascht denn eigentlich so habe
ich das mal verstanden macht man pläne
vorher nicht dann wenn man sie braucht
er dann sollte man sie haben die
bundesnetzagentur hat ihnen 2017 mal
aufgeschrieben über den stresstest und
2019 noch mal was passiert eigentlich
wenn wir auf einmal kein gas mehr ich
hätte mich gefreut dafür dass wir jetzt
einen kompletten plan in der schublade
gehabt hätten die man einfach nur hätte
umsetzen müssen den haben wir nun zu
gefunden ich dann noch mal ins
wirtschaftsministerium gucken aber ich
habe da nichts von gehört das was wir
gerade tun ist das vorlegen eines
schnellen maßnahmenpaket ist das
vorliegen einer massiven reduktion von
der abhängigkeit von energie aus
russland und dass wir das in so kurzer
zeit als ampel gemeinsam hinbekommen
dass aber auch robert habeck da so
vorprescht und so viel erreicht hat das
ist ein echter erfolg und das bedeutet
auch und das zeigt auch wie schnell und
wir vor wir sollten aber
aber
diese aktuelle energiepreis krise und es
ist richtig dass wir entlasten es ist
richtig dass wir an den
unterschiedlichen stellen ich habe nicht
alle noch mal aufzählen muss ich da
wieder haben sie genügend aus der
koalition heute gehört was alles gut
gelaufen ist was wir alles tun aber ich
will ein beispiel herausgreifen wo man
noch einmal verdeutlichen kann warum es
so sinnvoll ist dass wir jetzt entlassen
und wie wir entlasten denn was braucht
es bei externen schocks was braucht es
wenn es gerade aktuell eine krise gibt
und wir ein problem haben dann braucht
es schnelle konkrete maßnahmen die den
bürgerinnen und bürgern die den menschen
die aber auch den unternehmen direkt
helfen die dafür sorgen dass ganz
konkret an dieser stelle preise
und klar müssen wir preissignale
aufrechterhalten natürlich haben
preissignale immer eine wirkung und das
ist auch richtig so aber es ist trotzdem
auch korrekt den menschen die sich
fragen wie sie am ende des monats ihre
rechnung bezahlen wollen zumindestens
linderung zu verschaffen weil die
preissignale das haben wir gesehen
bleiben ja weiter hoch und deswegen ist
es richtig an die energie steuer
ranzugehen und die auf das europäische
mindestmaß abzusehen warum ist das
richtig weil es das thematisch korrekt
ist weil wir langfristig sehen werden
das natürlich preise steigen werden auch
dadurch dass wir erneuerbare augenbrauen
aufbaut auch dadurch dass wir
klimaschutz betreiben aber insbesondere
durch den co2 preis lägen hier in diesem
haus über den e t s noch niemand in
frage gestellt hat da werden preise
steigen deswegen sei aber richtig und
das ist als ziel von wirtschaftspolitik
ist es unter anderem im magischen
viereck die
preisstabilität das preisniveau stabil
zu halten und dieses preisniveau können
wir nur stabil halten wenn wir sowohl
investitionen anreizen denn wir dafür
sorgen dass ausbau schnell geht und wenn
wir gleichzeitig kosten senken das
fördert innovation an das sorgt für
niedrige kosten und das ist es was video
umsätzen schnell und gezielt da hat die
ampel bewiesen vielen dank
vielen dank der religion fehler damit
ist die aussprache beendet bevor ich die
aktuelle stunde werden entschuldigung
bevor ich in diesem tag und aufrufe gebe
ich ihnen das ergebnis der wahl eines
mitglieds des parlamentarischen
kontrollgremiums gemäß artikel 55 des
grundgesetzes bekannt mitgliederzahl des
hauses 736 abgegebene stimmzettel
683 ungültig keine mit ja haben gestimmt
426 abgeordnete mit nein haben bestimmt
220 ab heute enthaltungen 37 der akener
dr andré hahn adina § 2 absatz 3 des
gesetzes über die parlamentarische
kontrolle nachrichtendienstlicher
tätigkeit des bundes erforderliche
mehrheit von 369 stimmen erreicht er ist
damit als mitglied des parlaments bis
heute ins spiel
also beim zweiten mal hat es dann jetzt
geht klappt für andré hahn und damit
kommen wir zum nächsten
tagesordnungspunkt
da geht es um ein sofort zuschlag und
das einmal zahlungs gesetz die ampel
koalition möchte die
kindergrundsicherung einführen das ist
allerdings so weit ist
soll es einen sofort zuschlag für
betroffene kinder und jugendliche geben
monatlich anschluss von 20 euro und
außerdem soll es eben auch eine
einmalzahlung für erwachsene
leistungsberechtigte geben 200 euro
darauf hat sich die ampel koalition
geeinigt
und es werden hier auch zwei anträge der
linksfraktion beraten doch als erster
spricht nun der zuständige minister für
arbeit und soziales hubertus heil
das liegt daran der präsident dass der
kollege köhler wirklich große politik
ist herr präsident lieber kolleginnen
und kollegen der minister hat kann ihn
zu stehen dass sie meinen wahrscheinlich
längst aber
sowohl als auch
der präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen diese bundesregierung diese
koalition ist angetreten um
bekanntermaßen mehr fortschritt zu wagen
und fortschritt das war von anfang an
klar braucht vor allen dingen
investitionen die zukunft und wer in die
zukunft investieren will der muss in
unsere kinder investieren deshalb haben
wir uns vorgenommen noch in dieser
legislaturperiode eine eigenständige
kindergrundsicherung einzuführen und
damit einen echten paradigmenwechsel in
der familienförderung einzuleiten
und
jeder von uns weiß dass ein sehr großes
vorhaben aber ich freue mich auf die
umsetzung und ich freue mich auch auf
die umsetzung gemeinsam mit dem
finanzminister christian lindner und mit
der neuen familienministerin dieser
pause ich freue mich auf die
zusammenarbeit bei diesem großen
wichtigen thema
denn es geht um viel kinder die in armut
aufwachsen sind benachteiligt unserer
gesellschaft bei bildung ausbildung bei
gesellschaftlicher teilhabe und zwar hat
nicht selten ihr leben lang und das eben
meine damen und herren können wir uns in
deutschland nicht mehr leisten will
deutlich sagen dass das ziel dieser
bundesregierung das soziale herkunft
kein dauerhaftes schicksal für menschen
ist dass das leben für menschen offen
ist und dazu gehört auch zu erkennen
dass kinder die heute noch in der
grundsicherung sind eben keine kleinen
langzeitarbeitslosen sind sondern kinder
die ein recht auf ein offices leben
mit der kindergrundsicherung werden wir
deshalb dafür sorgen dass mehr soziale
sicherheit das respekt dass
teilhabechancen da sind und wir werden
kinder an butter mit bekämpfen heute
gehen wir einen schritt in diese
richtung aber einen wichtigen schritt
mit dem kinder sofort zuschlag in höhe
von 20 euro monatlich wollen wir
bedürftige familien und kinder besser
unterstützen solle ab ersten juli diesen
jahres gezahlt wird nicht einmalig
sondern monatlich den zuschlag erhalten
künftig bis zur einführung der
kindergrundsicherung wir werden das dann
über führen alle kinder die im haushalt
ihrer eltern wohnen und leistungen der
grundsicherung systeme oder den
kinderzuschlag bisher erhalten 20 euro
meine damen und herren das klingt für
viele menschen vor allen dingen hier
auch im deutschen bundestag die viel
mehr verdienen
ziemlich wenig aber erst einmal muss man
klar sagen den betroffenen familien
hilft es für jedes kind 20 euro und das
monat für monat ganz konkret für
menschen die es eben nicht dicke haben
zum beispiel wenn es um kinder geht und
wer kinder hat ich habe welche der weiß
das und so besuch sich leisten zu können
oder auch mal ein kinobesuch dass kinder
und jugendliche sich besser entfalten
können ihre stärken ausschöpfen können
das muss unser gemeinsames ziel sein ich
bin mir sicher meine damen und herren am
ende profitiert davon die gesamte
gesellschaft
wäre der präsident liebe kolleginnen
kollegen die pandemie hat den
allermeisten menschen schwer zu schaffen
gemacht den letzten jahren körperlich
seelisch und vielen auch finanziell die
sozialen härten der pandemie abzufedern
und für sozialen ausgleich zu sorgen das
ist unser anliegen das ist das gebot der
stunde seit dem letzten jahr haben wir
nicht nur mit der pandemie zu kämpfen
sondern auch in vielen bereichen mit
steigenden preisen das ist gerade bei
der debatte um das entlastungspaket im
anderen teil auch diskutiert worden und
auch der furchtbare krieg gegen die
ukraine heißt diese preissteigerung noch
mal an gerade die die es schon vor der
krise nicht leicht hatten müssen wir
deshalb jetzt gezielt unterstützen
menschen in der grundsicherung oder
familien mit geringen einkommen
deshalb haben wir zwei entlastungs paket
auf den weg gebracht und mit diesem
gesetz werden wir dafür sorgen dass
erwachsene leistungsberechtigte besser
unterstützt werden mit einer zahlung von
immerhin 200 euro ich sage auch an
dieser stelle wir haben solche zuschläge
auch in der großen koalition schon mal
gehabt das ist richtig um härten
abzufedern und wir werden wenn es
notwendig ist auch weitergehen ich will
aber auch hinzufügen dass beispielsweise
von den familienzuschlag denen diese
koalition auch umsetzen wird auch kinder
und familien in der grundsicherung
profitieren werden weil wir es eben
nicht anrechnen werden weil es einen
zuschlag aus kindergeld ist an dieser
stelle und das ist auch ein wichtiger
schritt
und wir haben weitere entlastung die wir
auf den weg gebracht haben nicht mit der
gießkanne sondern sozial ausgewogen mit
dem heizkostenzuschuss für
geringverdienerinnen geringverdiener im
wohngeld mit erhöhung des steuerlichen
grundfreibetrages mit der abschaffung
der eeg-umlage mit energie pauschale mit
vielen anderen maßnahmen meine damen und
herren es ist wichtig dass diese
gesellschaft solidarisch zusammen steht
um mit solch schwierigen zeiten menschen
zu helfen die es nicht leicht haben denn
die stärke unserer gesellschaft meine
damen und herren die bemisst sich vor
allen dingen an der frage wie man in
wirtschaftlich schwierigen zeiten auch
mit den schwächsten umgeht erst recht in
dieser krise es geht um geflüchtete es
geht um kinder es geht um
armutsgefährdete menschen sie brauchen
um solidarität und sie brauchen einen
starken sozialstaat das hier ist nicht
das ende der fahnenstange
dieses gesetz ist nicht alles gar keine
frage aber sei ein wichtiger schritt in
diesen zeiten der menschen konkret hilft
und deshalb bitte ich sie um zustimmung
zu diesem entwurf wir werden ihnen noch
ergänzen im verlauf des verfahrens bei
dem übergang von geflüchteten menschen
aus dem asylbewerberleistungsgesetz
1 sgb 2 das ist ein ganz ganz wichtiger
schritt der kommt noch dazu da bitten
wir sie im verfahren um zustimmung damit
wir das gesetz zum ersten juli in kraft
setzen können aber ist ein wichtiger tag
ein wichtiges gesetz mit dem kinder
sofort zuschlag bewerben zuschlägen und
mit diesem schritt den wir gemeinsam
gehen wollen herzlichen dank für
aufmerksamkeit
[Musik]
gesetz
12.000 familien mit etwa 30.000 kindern
sollen damit zusätzlich erreicht werden
erster redner nun in der aussprache ist
kein ptk für die unionsfraktion herr
präsident werte kolleginnen kollegen ich
möchte die nerven der ampelkoalition
nicht übermäßig strapazieren deshalb
verkünde ich die frohe botschaft gleich
zu beginn die union wir mehr
unterstützen dieses gesetz ausdrücklich
lassen sie mich das sagen und anzieht
auch das sehr leicht dieses gesetz zu
unterstützen weil sie de facto das
nachmachen was wir bereits mit der spd
in der letzten legislaturperiode
vorgemacht haben und bekanntlich ist ja
nachahmung die höchste form der
anerkennung was damals richtig war kann
heute nicht falsch sein aber ich muss
sagen endlich legen sie dieses gesetz
vor denn wir waren in der letzten
koalition herr minister deutlich
schneller wir haben anfang februar
letztes jahr uns auch so eine hilfe
vereinbart und bereits im selben monat
das sozial schutzpaket drei hier durch
den deutschen bundestag gebracht und im
mai die hilfen ausgezahlt sie haben zwei
monate gebraucht überhaupt zu klären ob
sie was machen wollen sie haben weitere
zwei monate gebraucht um jetzt dieses
gesetz vorzulegen und es dauert noch mal
zwei monate bis sie das geld auszahlen
ein halbes jahr haben sie jetzt
gebraucht so viel zeit haben die
menschen nicht in diesem land herr
minister
und angesichts der grassierenden
inflation ist tempo wirklich angesagt
gestern konnte man noch eine volle
einkaufstaschen mit nach hause tragen
heute kann man für deinen selben
geldbetrag die tasche am kleinen finger
nach hause tragen und der blick nach
frankreich bei allen außenpolitischen
herausfordern die waren der blick nach
frankreich zeigt 1 das thema kaufkraft
wird das hauptthema sein was millionen
von menschen in den nächsten jahren
bekümmern wird und ihr entlastungs paket
liefert darauf keine hinreichende
antwort ihre hilfen sind befristet sie
sind einmalig sie besteuern sie und
angesichts der tatsache dass
arbeitslosenversicherungsbeiträge und
krankenversicherungsbeiträge steigen
werden wird weniger netto vom brutto für
die menschen übrig bleiben und die
rentnerinnen und rentner und studenten
haben sie auch noch vergessen das ist
keine entlastungs politiker minister
diese politik muss man sich wahrlich
leisten können und
ich habe etwas sorge bei dieser
nachlässigkeit
denn seit monaten streiten sie ebenfalls
um das sanktionsmoratorium sie wollten
bis zum ende des jahres alle sanktionen
bei hartz 4 aussetzen gestern haben sie
im ausschuss dieses thema kurzfristig
von der tagesordnung runter genommen
wenn sie so weitermachen ist das jahr
vorbei man braucht diese
sanktionsmoratorium gar nicht mehr und
das zeigt schon dass bei diesen zwei
kleinen eingriffen die sie machen
wahnsinnig viel zeit vergeuden und das
lässt schlimmes befürchten für ihre mega
reform bürgergeld
denn da wollen sie ja die große reform
warten und die soll ja am ersten erst
nächstes jahr bereits gelten damit das
aber gut klappt muss die verwaltung das
sorgfältig vorbereiten also spätestens
ende september müssen sie hier mit dem
gesetz durch sein damit dpa noch drei
monate zeit hat das einigermaßen
hinzukriegen aber bis heute liegt noch
nicht mal ein eckpunkte entwurf vor und
dann muss sich schon fragen wo bleibt er
ich könnte mir vorstellen dass es daran
liegt dass sind nicht ganz einig sind
was sie wollen sie müssen nämlich die
frage beantworten wollen sie vom prinzip
fördern und fordern abweichen ja oder
nein sie müssen die frage beantworten ob
sie das arbeitslosengeld 2 erhöhen ja
oder nein sie müssen die frage
beantworten ob sie wieder zurück zum
bundessozialhilfegesetz wollen mit
individuellen rechtsansprüchen oder eben
beim portal recht bleiben wollen ich
vermute die rot grünen fraktion wollen
das und die fdp will es nicht ich kann
ihnen deshalb nur raten an die ampel
kurz und fangen sie endlich an zu
arbeiten die menschen die es am größten
haben und diesen lang haben das verdient
wenn sie das nicht schaffen stürzen sie
die party stürzen sie das
sozialgesetzbuch in einem chaos und das
haben die menschen nicht verdient
[Applaus]
und damit kommen wir zur neuen
bundesfamilienministerin
an lisa paus hält in dieser funktion ist
rede im deutschen bundestag
[Applaus]
herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen liebe
damen und herren die folgen der korona
pandemie und die steigenden konsum
preise seit beginn des ukraine krieges
bringen familien bringen
alleinerziehende bringen sozial
leistungsbezieher wirklich an ihre
belastungsgrenzen und will muss zuvor
wirtschaftlich schon nicht gut ging der
muss jetzt erst recht jeden cent
umdrehen bei dem zählen jeder euro und
das jeden tag und darum liegt ihnen
jetzt ein gesetz vor dass genau diese
menschen entlastet und das wir gestern
mit einem kabinettsbeschluss noch einmal
angepasst haben das wird ihnen zu gehen
mit einer einmalzahlung für
empfängerinnen und empfänger von
sozialleistungen jetzt nicht mehr von
100 sondern von 200 euro mit einer
einmalzahlung von 100 euro für alle die
arbeitslosengeld beziehen und auch noch
zu ändern dieser stelle
selbstverständlich die 100 euro
kinderbonus zur entlastung von familien
so nehmen wir druck von diesen menschen
meine damen und herren
haben auch jenen weg die mit nichts da
stehen weil sie ohne jedes hab und gut
vor dem krieg zu uns geflüchtet sind die
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer die ihr leben
nach deutschland gerettet haben wer von
ihnen bereits einen aufenthaltstitel hat
also registriert ist der held für seine
kinder kindergeld und das beinhaltet
ausdrücklich auch den kinderbonus ebenso
erleichtert bin ich darüber dass
hilfsbedürftige geflüchtete menschen und
da denke ich ganz konkret an die
holocaust-überlebenden die ihr mit hilfe
der durch claims conference nach
deutschland holen konnten künftig auch
leistungen aus dem sgb 2 und aus dem sgb
ii 12 erhalten und auch wer als nicht
hilfebedürftig gilt kann sich dennoch
gesetzlich krankenversichern lassen
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen diese
koalition ist von dem geist getragen ihr
wirklich möglichstes zu tun und menschen
dazu zu bringen ihr leben in die eigenen
hände zu nehmen
jeder nach seinen fähigkeiten die
aktuelle lage erfordert hier besonderen
einsatz auch unseren ganz besonderen und
auch finanziellen einsatz aber sorgt die
not und unsere maßnahmen sind es geht
eben immer auch im scharfen die dadurch
besser werden und damit um die zukunft
meine damen und herren
seit ich politik mache beschäftigt mich
ein thema und seine auswirkungen ganz
besonders wie wir in diesem land in
einem der reichsten länder der welt
endlich kinderarmut wirksam begegnen
können die politik ist erreichen kann
dass kinder endlich gleiche chancen
haben unabhängig von den finanziellen
möglichkeiten ihre eltern unabhängig
davon ob sie in bonn in bremen oder in
brandenburg aufwachsen und auch wirklich
unabhängig davon ob sich der vorname
dennis mit z oder mit es schreibt und
deshalb passt es wirklich sehr gut dass
ich meine erste rede heute als
ministerin zum kinder sofort zuschlagen
meine damen und herren
der kinder sofort zuschlag der kommt mit
diesem gesetz der kinder sofort zuschlag
ist ein erster ganz wichtiger schritt um
kinder vor armut zu schützen er wird ab
dem ersten juli ausgezahlt und damit
bekommen 2,9 millionen von armut
betroffene kinder in deutschland 20 euro
zusätzlich im monat dieser zuschlag wird
ohne weiteren antrag unbürokratisch
ausgezahlt und es gibt ihn dauerhaft und
lückenlos bis zur einführung der
kindergrundsicherung meine damen und
herren
um ein kindern gleiche chancen zu
ermöglichen müssen natürlich noch mehr
tun wir müssen politisch weichen stellen
für eine familienförderung die endlich
alle erreicht für eine gute
frühkindliche bildung für die
ganztagsbetreuung von grundschulkindern
eine bessere angemessene angebote an
fachkräfte und wir brauchen auch mehr um
eltern finanziell zu stärken und dafür
ist eben die kindergrundsicherung ein
ganz zentraler baustein und sie ist sie
eben nicht mehr des familienministeriums
auch nicht nur des arbeitsministeriums
sondern der ganzen bundesregierung meine
damen und herren
wenn alle menschen grundsicherung ist es
die bisherigen leistungen zu bündeln
konkret geht es um das kindergeld um
leistungen für kinder nach dem zweiten
und nach dem zwölften sozialgesetzbuch
um teile des bildungs und
teilhabepaketes um den kinderzuschlag
und ich füge hinzu wir sollten auch noch
mal über den kinderfreibetrag
miteinander sprechen
kindergrundsicherung soll automatisch
bei allen kindern ankommen ohne
bürokratische antrags wege so dass sie
endlich wirklich alle erreicht umso
wichtiger ist es dass im letzten monat
im märz bereits die interministerielle
arbeitsgruppe
eingerichtet worden ist und an diesem
projekt jetzt ressort übergreifend
arbeitet und ich direkt einsteigen kann
in die arbeit zu diesen so wichtigen
projekt für unser land meine damen und
herren
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
ich will in meinem amt alles dafür tun
dass die soziale ungleichheit in
deutschland nicht weiter zunimmt sondern
dass sie zurück geht ich finde mich
nicht damit ab dass menschen mit ihren
talenten und fähigkeiten auf der strecke
bleiben nur weil sie benachteiligt sind
oder weil sie benachteiligt werden das
können wir uns nicht leisten im
gegenteil es gibt viel zu gewinnen
packen wir es endlich
soweit also team neue bundesministerin
für familie senioren frauen und jugend
lisa paus die auf einen spiegel gefolgt
ist und die nächste rednerin kommt aus
der afg fraktion die red wings obfrau im
ausschuss für arbeit und soziales
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident sehr
geehrte damen und herren nach 16 jahren
merkel-regierung und gut 100 tagen ampel
regierung kann ein großer teil der
bürger dieses landes seine rechnungen
nicht mehr zahlen
gemäss eure stadt waren bereits 220
satte 22 5 prozent unserer bürger von
armut bedroht ein armutsrisiko übrigens
das klar über dem eu durchschnitt liegt
länder wie österreich oder frankreich
weisen deutlich geringerer armutsrisiken
auf genauer gesagt
wir die wir mit großem abstand die
größten zahlungen an die eu leisten
haben von den 27 eu ländern das
neuntgrößte
armutsrisiko mehr als jeder fünfte in
deutschland ist arm insgesamt 18 einhalb
millionen menschen in unseren ach so
reichen land das sicherlich
entwicklungsministerin schulze dafür
verantwortlich führt allen bürgern
dieser welt ein gutes leben zu
ermöglichen
dieses reiche land hat ziemlich arme
bürger meine damen und herren vielleicht
weil uns das fremde immer ein stück weit
wichtiger ist als das eigene
unser bürger sind in der tat so arm dass
wir jetzt dringend auf das
entlastungspaket der regierung
angewiesen ist das gilt natürlich auch
für die transfer geldempfänger denen
jetzt nach über zwei jahren pandemie ein
helikopter geld von 200 euro zugedacht
wird das ist richtig so wenn es auch
sehr spät kommt nur für die asylbewerber
in gemeinschaftsunterkünften braucht
dass das eigentlich nicht denn die
werden dort auch bei steigenden preisen
voll versorgt gut finden wir hingegen
dass die fast drei millionen armen
kindern unser land zukünftig 20 euro
mehr im monat haben sollen für diese
kinder wie auch für alle anderen kinder
wünschen wir uns aber dringend noch
etwas anderes sie haben am meisten unter
der pandemie gelitten und werden immer
noch damit geplagt dreimal pro woche
müssen sich berliner schüler noch oft
pure testen lassen und sich dazu wenig
gesunde teststäbchen den nase oder mund
schieben der fordert dass das umgehend
beendet wird
auch gibt es in vielen schulen unseres
landes immer noch eine masten pflicht
die mit einem fragwürdigen
hausrecht begründet wird auch das masken
tragen ist für kinder alles andere als
gesund wir fordern die regierung dass er
mit großem nachdruck auf darauf
hinzuwirken dass dies beendet wird
natur das entlastungsgesetz mit der
kurve pandemie die bürger müssten ja
vielleicht noch masken kaufen heißt es
dort und auch die pandemie bedingte
inflation sollen sie nicht ganz alleine
tragen diese begründung ist aber
fadenscheinig denn die inflation ist
natürlich nicht in erster linie pandemie
bedingt auch der ukraine krieg war
bisher nur in relativ kleinem umfang
toren beteiligt die zwei wesentlichen
ursachen sind vielmehr zum einen die mit
diversen steuerabgaben finanzierte
energiewende die mittel jährlich
steigende co2 steuer obendrauf nicht nur
sprit und strom verteuert sondern
gesamten warenkorb zudem wird das bau-
und zusätzlich belastet durch vertrieben
der wärmedämmung auflagen und immer
abenteuerlicher beheizung vorschriften
das treibt die kosten von bohrungen
mieten in absurde höhen die kaum noch
ein bürger erreichen kann
der zweite maßgebliche grund für die
inflation ist die lockere geldpolitik
der ezb die offenbar vergessen hat dass
ihre einzige pflicht aufgabe darin
besteht die preise stabil zu halten
dazu müsste sie einfach die zinsen
erhöhen tut sie aber nicht denn sie hat
sich ein zweites ihr überhaupt nicht zu
stehen das mandat ergriffen
nämlich die finanzierung überschuldeten
mittelmeerstaaten dies ist der eu
maastricht-vertrags ausdruck verboten
wird von der ezb aber trotzdem gemacht
durch in unfassbaren maße erfolgte
staatsanleihen ankäufe von vier
millionen euro also über 4000 milliarden
euro mit selbst gedrucktem geld
natürlich wenn die ezb nun aber die
zinsen erhöht die finanzierung der
mittelmeerstaaten an zu wanken und da
nicht sein kann was nicht sein darf
bleiben die zinsen auch bei uns niedrig
verlierer sind wie immer die bürger
nicht nur dass ihre sparguthaben dahin
schmelzen weil sie keine zinsen mehr
abwerfen jetzt explodieren auch noch die
einkaufspreise
und verringern zusätzlich die kaufkraft
ihrer einkommen das tut die eu unseren
bürgern an und unsere regierung werden
sie sich nicht natürlich noch einen
satzgewinn aber die falsche geldpolitik
der ezb kann nicht auf dauer mitbürger
entlastungspaket 'nen kompensiert werden
auch der ampel muss klar sein dass das
nicht geht ich habe jetzt gerade das
wort entzogen weil sie meiner dritten
auf hoffentlich gefolgt sind und 50
sekunden schon über die zeit waren
bittet
nächster redner ist der medienszene
fdp-fraktion für seine erste oder zu
seiner ersten parade
ja sehr geehrter präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
diskussionsgrundlage für die debatte ist
der korona zuschuss für bezieher von
leistungen von sozialleistungen der
monatliche sofort zuschlag in höhe von
20 euro was wir heute beschließen wollen
ich könnte ihm jetzt die ganze liste
noch aufzählen was eigentlich alles noch
immer entlastungs paket enthalten ist
aber das haben wir heute schon da habe
ich 20 mal gehört deswegen spare ich mir
das an der stelle aber ich möchte
trotzdem zu verfassen wir entlasten in
der breite der gesellschaft weil auch
der erarbeitende teil der bevölkerung
von den preissteigerungen betroffenes
beispielsweise durch die anhebung des
des grundfreibetrags bei der steuer
arbeitnehmerpauschbetrag abschaffung der
eeg-umlage aber
zeitgleich unterstützen die auch ganz
besonders stark diejenigen die besonders
stark von den preissteigerungen
betroffen sind und darum geht es dann
heute auch in unseren paketen denn dort
stellt sich die frage ob am ende des
monats überhaupt noch essen im
kühlschrank drin ist oder der monat
weiter läuft es stellt sich die frage ob
kinder und jugendliche noch mal geld
haben um ein schwimmbad zu fahren und
deswegen es ist richtig dass wir die
kinder und familien in den blick nehmen
und ermutiger ich bin etwas überrascht
dass sie jetzt auch mit den studierenden
angefangen sind weil sie haben der
pandemie nicht nur die kinder und
jugendlichen viel zu häufig vergessen
sondern sie haben auch vergessen eine
bafög-reform für die studierenden zu
machen die haben sie nämlich nicht in
den blick genommen die werden wir jetzt
angehen erste schritte werden jetzt
bereits erfolgen
doch liebe kolleginnen und kollegen aus
sicht der freien demokraten darf das
versprechen des sozialstaates nicht nur
seinen menschen in der bedürftigkeit zu
versorgen das versprechen des
sozialstaates muss es immer auch seien
menschen aus der bedürftigkeit zu
befreien wenn jemand einen
schicksalsschlag hat wenn er versucht
aus eigener kraft sich herauszuarbeiten
und er wird sicher sie haben nach der
bürgergeld reform gefragt und ich möchte
ihnen gerne genau ein ganz konkretes
beispiel dort männern eine
alleinerziehende mutter in hartz4 die
sich nicht einfach nur auf die
solidarität der gesellschaft verlassen
möchte sondern sich selbst etwas
erwirtschaften möchte sich anstrengt aus
eigener kraft diese frau die hat von der
mindestlohn erhöhung die die
richtigerweise heute eingebracht haben
recht wenig wenn sie einen mini job hat
und gleichzeitig hat vier bezieht denn
sie profitiert nicht immer davon von 100
euro freibetrag und dann wären 80
prozent angerechnet ihr kind wenn es
arbeiten geht als schüler da von den 450
euro nebenjob nur 170 euro behalten dass
es mehr ist der spitzensteuersatz kinder
und jugendlichen der zufall der geburt
entscheidet ob sich meine persönliche
anstrengung neben der schule arbeiten zu
gehen der tankstelle das zu verkaufen
regale einzuräumen ob sich das lohnt und
wenn sie nach der bürgergeld reformen
fragen wir werden die
hinzuverdienstgrenzen so anpassen dass
diejenigen die sich in unserer
gesellschaft anstrengungen belohnt
werden weil das haben sie in den letzten
16 jahren verpasst
und sollte und darum geht es uns als
freie demokraten bei der bürger gerd
reform studien und eine oecd
ländervergleich hat ergeben dass es in
deutschland sechs generationen braucht
bis man von einem niedrigeren bis zum
mittleren einkommen sich hocharbeiten
kann im vergleich in den skandinavischen
ländern sind es nur zwei jahre wir sind
auf einem platz mit china wenn wir über
die soziale mobilität in deutschland
sprecher ja es ist notwendig und
vollkommen richtig dass wir
unterstützung und entlastungsprogramm
auf und regt aber die wichtigste soziale
gesellschaftliche und
wirtschaftspolitische aufgabe ist es
dafür zu sorgen dass der soziale
hintergrund die hautfarbe das geschlecht
geldbeutel der eltern nicht über chancen
im leben entscheiden sondern leistung
fleiß und tatendrang
deswegen bleibt es aus meiner sicht ich
kam ja immer wieder auf fragen aus der
opposition auf hat der koalitionsvertrag
den überhaupt noch seine gültigkeit
müsste nicht alles hinterfragen werden
und ich finde es gut dass auch die
oppositionsparteien beispielsweise ihre
energiepolitik ihre sicherheitspolitik
hinterfragt dass jede parteien
demokratischen spektrum aktuell einfach
auf den prüfstand stellt wir haben den
koalitionsvertrag auch in der
sozialpolitik auf den prüfstand gestellt
ich möchte ihnen aber eines ganz
deutlich sagen diese koalition wird
beweisen dass wir auch trotz krisen die
wir bewältigen müssen weiter auf
fortschritt setzen müssen weil
stillstand ist auch der grund wieso wir
in der aktuellen situation sind und
unser fortschritt heißt die erneuerung
des aufstiegsversprechen der sozialen
marktwirtschaft wie ludwig erhard es
wollte und der freuen wir uns aber von
ihnen bei der unterstützung der bürger
geld reform ich habe ein punkt
beispielsweise genannt wir könnten über
den vermittlungs vorrang sprechen damit
menschen in ausbildung statt aushilfen
vermittelt werden wir können über das
weiterbildungsgeld sprechen weil ein
ganz großer teil der menschen hat vier
langzeitarbeitslose sind und keine
berufliche qualifikation
haben und wir könnten darüber sprechen
dass die kindergrundsicherung
aber das ist eine unmöglichkeit ist dass
das bundes teilhabepaket was ursula von
der leyen auf den weg gebracht hat nur
30 prozent der mittel bei den kindern
ankommt und deswegen werden sie dieses
paket digitalisieren mit einem kinde
chance im portal liebe ministerin ich
freue mich wenn sie dieses projekt
angehen ich glaube wir haben viel vor
vielen dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit
jetzt war der erst gerade deshalb müssen
nicht immer so sein
und jetzt trainer hat auch das
bürgergeld angesprochen die fdp möchte
er sozialleistungen wie wohngeld und 14
abschaffen stattdessen als bürgergeld
einführen und jens training ist auch
sprecher dafür jetzt jessica tati für
die linksfraktion
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen erinnern
sie sich noch vor ziemlich genau einem
jahr wurde hier schon mal eine corona
sonderzahlung für hartz4 empfänger
beschlossen damals noch von der großen
koalition damals in höhe von 150 euro
für ein halbes jahr damals haben die
grünen das gemeinsam mit der
linksfraktion
lautstark als viel zu niedrig kritisiert
was völlig richtig war jetzt bringt die
ampel einen noch niedrigeren zuschuss
100 euro für einen zeitraum von 18
monaten für alle masken schnelltests
hygieneartikel seit dem letzten sommer
also ich finde das ist oberpeinlich
und dann wollen sie weitere 100 euro
wegen der inflation drauflegen aufgrund
der kassen preissteigerungen bei
lebensmitteln und bei energie das klingt
gut aber die spannende frage dabei ist
wie kommen sie denn eigentlich auf
diesen betrag
denken sie sich da einfach und über 100
euro da wird sich schon jeder freuen
also das geht doch so nicht sie sind
auch verfassungsrechtlich verpflichte
die existenz heute abgesichert während
einer pandemie genauso wie während einer
hohen inflation ich lass das mal
zusammen im januar wurde der regelsatz
um lächerliche drei euro erhöht wenn ich
ihre geplanten 100 euro aufs jahr dazu
rechne sind dass weitere acht euro 33
also zusammen ein plus von zweieinhalb
prozent sie kennen die inflationsrate
über 7 prozent das heißt ihr zuschlag
leicht noch nicht mal den
kaufkraftverlust aus der leute die
gerade sich überlegen müssen mache ich
meinen wocheneinkauf oder bezahle ich
meine stromrechnung sie lassen die leute
hängen millionen menschen die unsere
unterstützung gerade am meisten brauchen
und das wird die linke so nicht
mitmachen
sie müssen sich mal ehrlich machen sie
kommen mit einmalzahlungen nicht mehr
weiter mit einem festlichen können sie
keine klaffende wunde versorgen nein das
grundproblem ist der klein gerechnete
regel sagt sie schon seit über 15 jahren
bei der berechnung schon den ganz
normalen zeiten reicht der hartz4 satz
vorne und hinten nicht rechnen sie mal
ehrlich die empirischen zahlen halten
und dann ergibt sich auch ein deutlich
höherer regelsatz nicht nur die linke
auch die wohlfahrtsverbände auch die
wissenschaft rechnet ihnen das seit
jahren vor mittlerweile schreiben ihnen
sogar jobcenter dass der druck im kessel
zu hoch wird und dass die leute wirklich
handfeste probleme bekommen und wir
haben ehrlich nachgerechnet und zwar mit
ihren eigenen modell mit dem modell der
bundesregierung
die leute brauchen
687 euro plus strom + weiße ware und
damit kann dann auch die inflation
abgefangen werden
die leute können nicht mehr auf ihre
zweifelhaften versprechen warten dass
mit dem bürgergeld bald bald alles
besser wird die probleme sind jetzt da
die leute haben jetzt
finanziellen druck und sie haben als
bundesregierung jetzt die pflicht zu
handeln
687 euro regelsatz das ist der respekt
den
das ist der respekt den die menschen
verdienen und minister weil das ist auch
der residenz bitte von dem sie die ganze
zeit hier daher reden fangen sie endlich
damit an
jessica team war dass die linksfraktion
hat hier zwei anträge eingereicht in dem
sie unter anderem auch fordert dass es
zahlungen für die sogenannte weiße ware
gibt das sind
langlebige gebrauchsgüter wie zum
beispiel waschmaschinen sarah lag am
spricht jetzt für die spd fraktion
sehr geehrter herr präsident sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen fast
jedes fünfte kind in unserem land lebt
in armut das können und das dürfen wir
nicht hinnehmen denn armut in
deutschland bedeutet dass kinder auf
dinge verzichten müssen die für den
großteil der gesellschaft
selbstverständlich sind hier geht es um
ein warmes und gesundes mittagessen oder
auch um materialien für die schule es
geht aber auch um soziale ausgrenzung
darum dass kinder auf hobbys mit ihren
freunden verzichten müssen oder den
kindergeburtstag sie werden also nicht
nur ökonomisch benachteiligt sondern
auch sozial und nicht nur dass armut
leider genauso vererbt wie
vermögenswerte und damit wird deutlich
dass in deutschland die chancen von
kindern und jugendlichen immer noch vom
geldbeutel der eltern abhängen das ist
ein teufelskreis ungerecht und unfair
von sozialdemokraten ist klar dass wir
diesen teufelskreis durchbrechen und für
kinder gerät ihre chancen
herstellen müssen unser wichtigstes
instrument wird dabei die
kindergrundsicherung sein die im
koalitionsvertrag beschlossen wurde
damit wir aber eine kindergrundsicherung
bekommen die ihren namen auch verdient
die kinder und jugendliche aus sichtbare
und aus verdeckter abend holt benötigtes
zeit genauigkeit und gute planung diese
sozialstaatliche reform ist ein
paradigmenwechsel und das geht leider
nicht von heute auf morgen um die zeit
bis dahin zu überbrücken haben wir uns
für ein sofort zuschlag entschieden erst
eine sofortmaßnahme damit familien mit
kindern etwas mehr finanziellen
spielraum bekommen er soll die kinder
und familien entlassen die es am
dringendsten brauchen konkret geht es um
eine zahlung von 20 euro pro kind im
monat alle leistungsberechtigten kinder
jugendlichen und jungen erwachsenen
haben einen anspruch darauf erreicht
also die familien die kein ausreichendes
einkommen erzielen und auch wenn sich 20
euro nicht gerade nach vielen jahren
möchte ich hier an dieser stelle noch
einmal auf etwas hinweisen dass ich über
diesen gesetzentwurf besonders wichtig
finde und zwar dass es sich um die
monatliche zahlung handelt und geld mit
dem familienfest planen und rechnen
können bis wir eine kindergrundsicherung
haben
der sofort zuschlag so zum ersten juli
22 eingeführt werden und erreicht 2,9
millionen kinder die in armut leben es
ist klar erst mit der
kindergrundsicherung werden wir ein
wirklich wirksames instrument gegen
kinderarmut in unserem land haben doch
der sofort zuschlag ist eine schnelle
wirksame entlastung für viele familien
und ein schritt in die richtige richtung
einer großen lösung werden wir weiter
arbeiten vielen dank
sarah war das und wir haben es
investiert sie ist vorsitzende der
kommission für die kinder das ist ja
eine kommission im bundestag ein
unterausschuss des familienausschusses
der sich um die belange von kindern und
jugendlichen kann
und kollegen
kinderarmut ist eine traurige realität
in deutschland werfen sie zum beispiel
einen blick ins herz unserer hauptstadt
in meinem wahlkreis berlin mitte ganz in
der nähe vom deutschen bundestag wächst
fast jedes zweite kind unterhalb der
armutsgrenze auf die kollegin sagt dass
gerade insgesamt ist es hierzulande fast
jedes fünfte kind
dabei müssen wir uns bewusst machen was
kinderarmut bedeutet
es bedeutet nicht mit den freunden
sportverein spielen weil die
mitgliedschaft zu teuer ist im
unterricht zurückfallen weil das geld
für den nachhilfeunterricht oder der ort
der ruhige ort für die schulaufgaben
vielen kinder armut hat viele gesichter
und wir müssen uns alle des problems
stellen die 20 euro pro monat sofort
zuschlag die sind ein anfang sie sind
besser als nichts aber mehr als ein
finanzielles trostpflaster sind sie
nicht
und auch die von der ampel geplante
einmalzahlung ist er ein teures placebo
zur wirksamen bekämpfung von armut sind
vielmehr auch strukturelle maßnahmen
gefragt da sprechen wir über andere
herangehensweisen und ich möchte hier
zwei gesondert hervorheben
erstens brauchen wir bessere anreize die
kinder gezielt fördern ein
ganzheitliches konzept das chancen und
bildungsgerechtigkeit zur priorität
macht
meilensteine sind das bildungspaket und
das starke familien gesetz übrigens
beides gesetzesinitiativen die von der
cdu csu fraktion in den letzten
legislaturperioden auf den weg gebracht
wurden und genau hier muss weiter
angesetzt werden
[Applaus]
zweitens kommen wir zu einem
wesentlichen punkt der bislang kaum
angesprochen wurde es braucht eine
starke soziale infrastruktur mit einem
englischen verbundenen netz an helfern
anlaufstellen und beratungen damit die
hilfe dort ankommt wo sie gebraucht wird
dann mit familien gezielt unterstützt
werden können gerade jetzt gerade als
hilfe für jene kinder die besonders von
der kommune pandemie betroffen waren
meine damen und herren wir als cdu csu
stehen an der seite der familien in
unserem land statt eines halbherzigen
sofort zuschlags braucht es ein ernst
gemeintes sofortprogramm mit echter
unbürokratische unterstützung für
einkommensschwache familien und mit
lösungen die kinderarmut ganzheitlich
bekämpfen vielen dank
zu den kleinen als nächstes zu helfen
die kollegin annika spd
sehr geehrter herr prof sehr geehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen liebe zu
schauen wie wir in dieser debatte
bereits mehrfach gehört haben aus
verschiedenen richtungen sind wird
derzeit mit mehreren krisen kommt von
trier konfrontiert die klimakrise die
globale corona pandemie sowie die
angriffskriege russland sowie der
angriffskrieg russlands auf die ukraine
stellen auf täglich vor neue
herausforderungen
die auswirkungen dieser krisentreffen
vor allem die menschen besonders hart
die es in ihrem leben eh schon nicht so
leicht haben wenn nur ein geringes
einkommen und kam vermögen hat kann
massive kostensteigerungen bei
lebensmitteln energiepreise im wohnraum
nicht so einfach ausgleichen klar ist
dass systemische krisen auch
systematisch wohl durchdachte und auf
dauer angelegte antworten brauchen daher
haben wir uns für diese
legislaturperiode große reformprojekte
vorgenommen die familien erwerbslose und
sozialhilfeempfängern dauerhaft und
krisenhaft krisenfest vor armut schützen
sollen die kindergrundsicherung wird
kinder und jugendliche in diesem land
unabhängig vom einkommen der eltern
absichern weil jedes kind es verdient
hat frei von armut aufzuwachsen
die kinder sofort zuschlag ist auf dem
weg dorthin der erste wichtige schritt
das neue bürger in geld wird eine kultur
auf augenhöhe schaffen ermöglicht ein
leben in würde und mit respekt und
fördert eine nachhaltige integration in
den arbeitsmarkt diese reform sind der
richtige weg um unsere sozialsysteme
krisenfest zu machen die von armut
betroffene menschen können aber gerade
nicht auf die große reform warten
sondern sie brauchen jetzt akute
unterstützung um ihre leben und ihren
lebensunterhalt finanzieren zu können
daher bin ich sehr froh dass die
bundesregierung gleich zwei entlastungs
paket auf den weg gebracht hat um
schnelle abhilfe zu schaffen die und
lasst euch pakete umfassen 200 euro für
empfänger von hartz 4
asylbewerberleistungsgesetz und
sozialhilfe 100 euro familien bonus für
alle kinder die kinder geld kriegen 300
euro für erwerbstätige 9 euro flat für
die nutzung von öffentlichen
verkehrsmitteln den heizkostenzuschuss
für wohngeldempfänger
all dies 54 millionen menschen in
unserem land in dieser krisensituation
das ist gut und das ist wichtig
und wenn wir hilfe in der krise sprechen
dann möchte ich auch noch sagen dass ich
mich sehr darüber freue dass die
geflüchteten aus der ukraine jetzt zum
ersten juni auf 1 sgb 2 geholt werden
das bedeutet eine deutliche verbesserung
ihrer krankenversicherung schafft
zugänge zu den leistungen der jobcenter
und entlastet und so kommunen ich bin
ein beteiligten die das da die das
möglich gemacht haben sehr dankbar und
ich bin vor allem auch danke all
denjenigen die freiwillig in ihrer
freizeit helfen die menschen aufzunehmen
und zu versorgen darauf bin ich sehr
stolz das ist gelebte solidarität und so
meistern wir auch diese krisen vielen
dank
annika klose war das internet können wir
zur letzten rednerin in dieser debatte
und das ist sylvia bauer aus der
unionsfraktion und sie ihr sprecherin
für familie senioren frauen und jugend
ihrer fraktion
[Applaus]
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen zunächst einmal auch von mir
auch im namen unserer arbeitsgruppe
herzlichen glückwunsch frau
familienministerin paus ich wünsche
ihnen alles gute in ihrem abend zum
wohle der familien in deutschland wir
freuen uns auf eine konstruktive
zusammenarbeit
sie haben in ihrem koalitionsvertrag im
dezember versprochen jetzt legen sie den
gesetzentwurf vor ein sofort zuschlag in
höhe von 20 euro im monat und dies so
steht's in ihrem gesetzentwurf soll
finanzielle spielräume schaffen und dazu
beitragen die lebensumstände und chancen
von kindern zu verbessern dieses ziel
unterstützen wir ausdrücklich und werden
das sehr konstruktiv begleiten jetzt im
gesetzgebungsverfahren
allerdings hat sich zwischen dezember
koalitionsvertrag und heute so einiges
verändert die realitäten haben sich
einfach verschoben und ich glaube
einfach nicht dass 20 euro im monat
tatsächlich in der lage sind finanzielle
spielräume für kinder in deutschland
tatsächlich zu verbessern und chancen zu
verbessern wir haben eine inflationsrate
von 7,3 jetzt im april 74 prozent bei
einem kinderzuschlag von 209 euro bei
der geldbedarf inzwischen
285 bis hin
376 euro sind 20 euro alleine durch die
inflation komplett weg da bleibt kein
einziger cent für einen finanziellen
spielraum über tatsächlich kann man
einfach sagen vor ihrem
koalitionsvertrag hatten die betroffenen
kinder jugendlichen jungen erwachsenen
mehr geld in der tasche als sie jetzt im
juli mit ihrem sozialen mit ihrem sofort
zuschlag haben werden das heißt wir
erwarten dass dort im rahmen der hilfen
nachdem im rahmen der beratungen nach
gearbeitet wird und wir werden das
entsprechend unterstützen
frau coleen dialoge zwischen flüelen
kann
dazu haben wir aber auch noch konkrete
ideen was man verbessern kann frau
bundesministerin wir haben noch vor
ihrer zeit hat meine kollegin gitta
connemann eine anfrage an die haus
geschickt so kinder zum kinder sofort
zum zum kinder so zum kinderzuschlag und
zwar ging es darum dass ein
eine familie aus durch longo witt aus
dem erwerbseinkommen rausgerutscht ist
rein in den kranken geld und dann wird
eben der kinderzuschlag nicht mehr
gezahlt und die familie muss auch auf
die leistungen aus dem bildungs und
teilhabepaket
verzichten ihre antrag ihrer
staatssekretären aus dem haus war eben
nicht wir prüfen das besuchen die lösung
wir gucken uns das mal an sondern sie
hat es schlichtweg abgelehnt das wäre
ein ganz konkreter fall wo man familien
in der aktuellen zeit wenn sie in den
kranken geldbezug rutschen helfen können
und ich wünsche mir wünschen wenn sie
sich das noch einmal anschauen unser für
uns geht anliegen von bürgerinnen und
bürgern erst geben notwendige
nachjustierungen vornehmen und dann eben
familienpolitische maßnahmen zielgenau
mit bund und land und kommunen auf den
weg bringen und dabei begleiten wir sie
sehr gerne vielen dank vielen dank
[Applaus]
werden sich die aussprache
interfraktionell wird beweisen der
vorlagen auch den drucksachen 14
1111 1404 und 1502 an der tagesordnung
auch für den ausschüssen vorgeschlagen
gibt es weitere beweise dass vorschläge
das sehe und höre ich nicht als
verfahren wir wie vorgeschlagen auf den
tagespunkt 15 und da wird es wieder um
den klimawandel beziehungsweise den
klimaschutz gehen schon gestern gab es
ja eine aktuelle stunde zum klimawandel
damals war der bericht des pcs
anlass und auch die cdu/csu-fraktion
beschäftigt sich mit dem klimawandel und
den möglichen maßnahmen um diesen
aufzuhalten und hat daher einen antrag
vorgelegt mit dem
titel klimaanpassung passieren zum
schutz von menschenleben der natur und
zum erhalt des wohlstands und in diesem
antrag fordert sie mehrere maßnahmen
unter anderem ein nationales klima
anpassungs gesetz vorzulegen aber auch
zum beispiel zu überdenken ob der
schutzstatus des bibers eingeschränkt
werden sollte dort wo schäden an buch
wasserschutz anlagen zu befürchten sind
vielen dank herr präsident werte
kolleginnen und kollegen das thema
klimawandel besteht aus zwei
wesentlichen säulen zum einen aus der
vermeidung von treibhausgasen auf der
einen seite eben und auf der anderen
seite aus der anpassung an den bereits
stattfindenden klimawandel und beide so
sind aus unserer sicht gleichbedeutend
und um beide seiten müssen wir uns
gleich stark kümmern darum haben wir in
unser wahlprogramm als cdu csu die
forderung aufgenommen dass ein klima
anpassungs gesetz verabschiedet werden
muss sie liebe ampel fraktionen sind auf
den zug aufgesprungen und haben
ebenfalls ein klima anpassungs gesetz
angekündigt das begrüßen wir sehr
deshalb ist es umso wichtiger dass jetzt
zeitnah vom findungs modus in den
handlungs modus kommen und dieses klima
anpassungs gesetz vorlegen das
von um
bundesumweltministerin steffi lemke ende
märz vorgestellte sofortprogramm
klimaanpassung wird unserer meinung nach
der herausforderung des klimawandels der
klimaanpassung nicht ausreichend gerecht
vielmehr schafft das konzept schaffen
die vorschläge unnötige und aus unserer
sicht auch teure doppelstrukturen
zum beispiel soll in zukunft der bund
mit der kommunal richtlinie werden ja
schon die klimamanager beförderung in
zukunft will der bund zusätzlich auch
noch anpassungs manager fördern dass es
in dem sofortprogramm zum zur
klimaanpassung so vorgesehen meiner
meinung nach unserer meinung nach
sollten wir lieber die förderung für die
klimaschutzmanager verstetigen und ihre
kompetenz erweitern um das thema klima
anpassung ich weiß es aus meinem
wahlkreis dass die klimaschutzmanager
nadal das sehr gute arbeit leisten und
ich verstehe nicht warum man da noch
eine zusätzliche doppelstruktur schafft
ich verstehe auch den unterschied nicht
zwischen den klimaschutz managern und
den klima anpassung des managers sollte
beides und nach unter einem dach das ist
unserer meinung nach eine unnötige
doppelstrukturen lieber sollten diese
gelder für die wichtigen klima
anpassungsmaßnahmen eingesetzt werden
meine damen und
es gibt viel zu tun das haben uns die
verheerenden fluten im letzten sommer in
teilen nordrhein westfalens und der von
rheinland-pfalz gezeigt die unendliches
leid und zerstörung
hervorgerufen haben in unserem antrag
schlagen wir viele ganz konkrete und
effektive maßnahmen vor zum einen muss
der hochwasserschutz ausgeweitet werden
das ein ganz wesentlicher punkt der
klima vorsorge wir fordern unter anderem
eine weiterentwicklung des nationalen
hochwasserschutz programms von bund und
ländern deshalb sollte zusätzlich auch
noch unserer meinung nach das ist ein
zusätzliches thema der schutzstatus des
bibers dort eingeschränkt werden wo
schäden an
hochwasserschutzanlagen zu befürchten
sind ebenfalls sollte man sich den
schutzstatus des wolfes gerade da
besonders anschauen wo eine weide
tierhaltung für den küsten und flussufer
schutz oder zb auch auf almen für den
erosionsschutz notwendig ist meine damen
und herren das sind ganz konkrete
vorschläge und wir würden uns sehr
freuen wenn sie diese aufgreifen würden
meine damen
außerdem fordern wir mehr unterstützung
für private haushalte und kommunen für
die hochwasser prävention zb in form von
kfw förderprogrammen mit dem dann auch
gebäude vor hochwasser mit diesen
geldern dann auch geschützt werden und
in dem zum beispiel bauliche
präventionsmaßnahmen auch gefördert
werden im katastrophenschutz und in der
katastrophenhilfe müssen dringend lehren
aus den vergangenen fluten gezogen
werden hier muss der zivilschutz
gestärkt werden und stärker in den fokus
gerückt werden mit und mit den
zusätzlichen haushaltsmitteln dann auch
unterlegt werden ein mittel gegen
starkregen ereignisse sind auch die
sogenannten schwamm stätte die zum
beispiel durch grünanlagen oder
dachbegrünungen regenwasser aufnehmen
und damit wird dann auch verhindert dass
wasser das regenwasser
ungebremst in die überforderten
kanalisationen dann auch fließt
ja wo auf der einen seite viel wasser
ist fehlt es auch auf der anderen seite
einige gegenden ich komme zum beispiel
aus so einer trockenen region and
franken haben durch den klimawandel
unter extremer trockenheit zu leiden
auch die landwirtschaft die wahrheit der
weinbau in vielen bereichen merkt man
diese trockenheit und deshalb brauchen
wir ein verbessertes regenwasser
management wir müssen regenwasser
speichern
aber auch abwasser
wiederaufbereiten so dass zb mit diesem
aufbereiteten wasser dann auch
grünanlagen auch bewässert werden können
und es muss auch daran geforscht werden
wie man vielleicht mit aufbereitetem
abwasser auch in der landwirtschaft die
flächen bewässern kann
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen sie sehen
das thema klima anpassung ist sehr
vielschichtig wir haben uns intensiv
auch mit allen arbeitsgemeinschaft mit
diesem thema auseinandergesetzt es ist
ein sehr fundierte antrag ich hoffe sie
haben alle vorschläge gelesen und wir
würden uns wirklich sehr freuen wenn
dann in das klima anpassungs gesetz
viele dieser vorschläge einfließen
würden das verstehe ich unter einer
konstruktiven oppositionsarbeit vielen
herzlichen dank
anja weisgerber war das für die
unionsfraktion und sie sehen ist wir
erwarten auch ein statement vom us
präsidenten joe biden der noch mal
weitere hilfen für die ukraine zu sagen
möchte braucht dafür die zusage des us
kongresses und ein statement ist
angekündigt wenn das beginnt gehen wir
natürlich live darauf jetzt aber erst
einmal im bundestag rainer keller für
die spd fraktion
das wird wahrscheinlich nichts mehr
werden in diesem leben aber trotzdem
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
ich habe mich gefreut dass dieser antrag
von der cdu/csu eingebracht wurde weil
klimaanpassung ist wirklich ein extrem
wichtiges thema und dem müssen wir uns
in diesem hause hier widmen ein schelm
wer böses dabei denkt wir haben wahlen
in nrw und in schleswig holstein
und just in diesem moment kommt dieser
antrag eben aufs tapet finde ich sehr
spannend aber gehen wir mal weiter vor
die kinder von heute werden zwei bis
sieben mal mehr extreme erleben als
ihren großeltern so lautet der titel
einer mitteilung des potsdam instituts
für klimafolgenforschung von september
anlass für die veröffentlichung war eine
studie zur zukünftigen extremwetter
ereignissen im science mehr gesehen die
ergebnisse dieser studie lassen die
beteiligten forscherinnen und forscher
zu einem eindeutigen schluss kommen die
menschen die heute unter 40 jahre alt
sind werden auf grund von dürren
überschwemmungen
ernteausfälle nein leben führen welches
man nur noch als beispiellos bezeichnen
kann
die herausforderungen denen wir uns
stellen müssen sind immens dennoch
dürfen wir nicht den kopf in den sand
stecken sondern müssen uns zur verfügung
stehenden mittel die wir haben
und die instrumente dazu nach allen
möglichkeiten entschieden nutzen im
koalitionsvertrag haben wir das so
zahlreiche maßnahmen vereinbart damit
wir bei der klimaanpassung entscheidende
schritte vorankommen
den veränderungen müssen wir
zielgerichtet begegnen wohlgemerkt
zielgerichtet dazu benötigt es an vielen
stellen einen regelrechten umbau des
landes damit die nächsten generationen
besser mit den sicherlich auftretenden
extremwetter ereignissen umgehen können
[Applaus]
ein projekt das man nordrhein
westfälischen heimat zeigt wie solche
maßnahmen aussehen können dort ist es
über viele jahre hinweg gelungen entlang
der lippe einem zufluss zum einen dem
flusslauf weitesgehend auf seinen
natürlichen zustand zurückzuführen
die renaturierten und ufer tragen nicht
nur zum klimaschutz bei sondern sie
bieten auch natürliche
überschwemmungsflächen und sorgen damit
für einen effektiven hochwasserschutz
dieses auf regionaler und kommunaler
ebene realisierte programm ist somit
eine win win situation für alle
beteiligten und eben auch die natur und
davon brauchen wir in diesem unserem
land dort nicht mehr
wie man jedoch klimaanpassung nicht
angehen sollte zeigt sich leider auch in
nrw mit dem 20 21 verabschiedeten
klimaanpassung gesetz hat die dortige
landesregierung eine hülle ohne substanz
geschaffen ohne leben
die kommunen werden seitdem nicht mehr
in die konkreten maßnahmen eingebunden
ebenso wurden keine zusätzlichen
finanzmittel zur verfügung gestellt
da frage ich mich schon die das eingehen
soll das wird nicht funktionieren
darüber hinaus wurden mit dem gesetz die
ergebnisse und erkenntnisse des
klimaschutzplan santa fe vollständig
ignoriert
diesen erfahrungen wären aber eine
wichtige grundlage gewesen für eine für
an der erfolgreiche und wirkungsvolle
klimaanpassung
denn die 66 darin vereinbarten maßnahmen
waren ein ergebnis eines intensiven
dialogs aller gesellschaftlichen gruppen
in nrw hier wurde von der cdu chancen
vertan ganz eindeutig es wird nicht
einmal mehr deutlich und dass ihr
vorgelegte antrag oder es wird einmal
wieder einmal mehr deutlich dass ihr
vorgelegte antrag nicht ihrem handeln
entspricht denn dort wo sie noch
regierungsverantwortung zum tragen
gelingt es ihnen nämlich nicht
daher ist es gut dass sie im bund
bereits in der opposition sind und diese
rolle auch bald wieder einnehmen werden
klimaanpassung hat jedoch nicht nur
etwas mit notwendigen baulichen oder
renaturierungsmaßnahmen zu tun vielmehr
ist es eine gesamtgesellschaftliche
aufgabe der hohen stellen müssen der
richtige umgang mit klimafolgen und den
daraus entstehenden akuten
notsituationen rettet leben und schützt
infrastruktur wir haben die beispiele
alle noch im kopf letztes jahr an der
ahr und in nordrhein westfalen in der
eifel
und wenn man dann weiter schaut 70
prozent der naturkatastrophen der
letzten zehn jahre sind laut einer
studie des internationalen roten kreuzes
auf den klimawandel zu führen es sind
erschreckende zahlen
dies sehe ich auch bestätigt würde meine
erfahrung als ehemaliger
katastrophenschutzbeauftragte
und wir sind immer mehr von solchen soll
der situation oder mit solchen situation
konfrontiert
extremwetter ereignisse die durch den
menschen machten klimawandel verursacht
werden begegnen wir immer mehr in der
gefahrenabwehr und die müssen wir
entgegentreten
hier meine lieben kolleginnen und
kollegen
müssen wir deutlich besser werden um
menschen und natur den schutz zu
gewähren den sie verdienen staatliches
handeln muss an vielen stellen deutlich
besser werden und dafür stehen wir hier
und jetzt sehen wir noch ein letzter
satz gewöhnt und das wird nicht mehr
funktionieren weil zwei sekunden ein
letzter satz habe ich noch
wir müssen auch gucken das ist enorm
wichtig dass sich länder mit an bord
holen will gerade das was sie in ihrem
antrag formuliert haben im bereich des
katastrophenschutzes zu forcieren ist
sache der länder
[Applaus]
einen schönen guten tag liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen auch von meiner
seite und wir führen fort in der debatte
unter nächste redner ist andreas
plakataktion und andreas beck ist
umweltpolitischer sprecher seiner
fraktion
werte frau präsidentin werte kolleginnen
und kollegen bei keiner partei ist die
diskrepanz zwischen anspruch und
wirklichkeit so groß wie bei den grünen
als angebliche friedens und umweltschutz
parteien der opposition gestartet sind
sie als tatsächliche kriegs und
umweltzerstörung partei in der regierung
gelandet das junge welt politik der
neuen bundesregierung den ansprüchen der
afg nicht genügt es nicht überraschend
überraschend ist dass die klimapolitik
der neuen bundesregierung vor allem der
grünen noch nicht einmal den eigenen
ansprüchen genügen dass sie auch andere
gründe warum diese antrag heute vorliegt
in der opposition kritisierten die
grünen die alte bundesregierung keine
klima politik aus einem guss gemacht zu
haben was machen die grünen in der
regierung für den klimaschutz sind drei
bundesministerien verantwortlich beim
sofortprogramm klimaanpassung wird eine
doppelstruktur geschaffen damit haben
die grünen die fragmentierung des
klimaschutzes auf die spitze getrieben
der antrag von cdu und csu zur
klimaanpassung gemeint ist die anpassung
an den klimawandel hat licht und
schatten er stellt eine wichtige
diskussionsgrundlage da dem klimawandel
gab es gibt es und wird es immer geben
menschen hatten und haben sich angepasst
und werden sich immer anpassen wir
unterstützen also die wiedervernässung
von mooren die extremwetter tolerante
aufforstung von wäldern die bekämpfung
der wasserknappheit und die begrünung
von städten doch cdu und csu fordern in
ihrem antrag auch den schutzstatus des
bibers dort einzuschränken
wo schäden an hochwasserschutzanlage
nicht etwa eingetreten sondern
befürchtet werden sie fordern den
schutzstatus des wolfes bundesweit
insbesondere aber dort einzuschränken wo
eine weide tierhaltung für den küsten
und flussufer schutz notwendig ist die
bundesweite einschränkung des wolfs
schutzes hat jedoch weder etwas mit
klimaanpassung noch mit hochwasserschutz
zu tun sie instrumentalisieren hier den
hochwasserschutz für die einschränkung
des biba und wolf schutzes und das ist
bei allem verständnis für die probleme
damit werfen und mit bibern haben
eigentlich unangebracht und ihrer nicht
würdig doch damit nicht genug cdu und
csu fordern beim katastrophenschutz die
lehren aus der flutkatastrophe von juli
2021 zu ziehen doch die im bund und oder
in den ländern regierenden parteien
sollten sich vor allem zunächst an die
eigene nase fassen es waren die spd
geführte landesregierung in rheinland
pfalz und die cdu-geführte
landesregierung nordrhein westfalen die
mit ihren innen und umweltministern
völlig versagt haben sie wehrte kollegen
und kollegen sind in diesem punkt eben
kein teil der lösung sondern sie sind
teil des problems die bürger in
rheinland pfalz und nordrhein westfalen
warten bis heute darauf dass jemand die
politische verantwortung für die
flutkatastrophe vom juli 2021 übernimmt
immerhin kann ich dem antrag von cdu und
csu nicht entnehmen dass sie mit der
klimakrise vom völligen versagen beim
katastrophenschutz ablenken wollen
anders die landesregierung in
rheinland-pfalz und nordrhein-westfalen
sowie die bundesregierung im
sofortprogramm klimaanpassung heißt es
beispielsweise ich zitiere bereits heute
zeigt sich eine neue dimension von
schäden infolge der klimakrise die
verheerende flutkatastrophe vom juli
2021 hat rund 190 menschenleben
gefordert diese instrumentalisierung der
flutkatastrophe vom juli 2021 für die
klimapolitik der bundesregierung ist
schäbig und widerwärtig die wut wurde
nicht durch ein klima sondern ein
wetterphänomen verursacht tote und
verletzte gab es weil der
katastrophenschutz der landesregierungen
in rheinland-pfalz und
nordrhein-westfalen
ungenügend war und ist vielleicht würde
auch den ein oder anderen grünen
minister ein rücktritt gut tun ohne amt
kommt möglicherweise der verstand vielen
dank
andreas blick war das hat hier einige
maßnahmen im antrag der unionsfraktion
begrüßt andere abgelehnt auf ihn folgt
nun harald ebner für bündnis 90 die
grünen erst vorsitzender im ausschuss
für umwelt naturschutz nukleare
sicherheit und verbraucherschutz
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin wäre die
kolleginnen und kollegen die afg hat
sich gestern bei der debatte zur
klimakrise mit ihren hasserfüllten
hilfsbeiträge zu dem thema schon derart
diskreditiert und sie herr kollege blick
haben das heute noch mal bestätigt der
union möchte ich zu rufen besser spät
als nie vor einem monat hat die
bundesumweltministerin lemke das
sofortprogramm klimaanpassung und das
aktionsprogramm natürliche klimaschutz
auf den weg gebracht das war dringend
notwendig denn viele jahre räumte
klimaschutz fordern jetzt von uns dass
wir uns an die heute schon
unausweichlichen folgen der klimakrise
anpassen müssen und da ist es schön dass
auch ihnen endlich mal was dazu einfällt
es grenzt allerdings auch an
dreistigkeit
60 16 jahre lang wirksamen klimaschutz
zu bekämpfen und danach die
nachfolgeregierung dazu aufzurufen die
scherben zusammenzukehren und dass wir
ihnen jetzt noch den unterschied
zwischen klimaschutz und klimaanpassung
erklären müssen das spricht bände ihre
eigene ihre eigene ehemalige kanzlerin
muss sie eingestehen dass in ihren 16
jahren kanzlerinnen schafft in punkto
klimaschutz
nicht ausreichend viel passiert sei gut
wenn sie sich da jetzt neu sortieren man
könnte aber diesen an der union auch
überschreiben mit die union auf der
suche immerhin haben sie auch schon was
entdeckt sie haben entdeckt dass
vorsorgeprinzip frau kollegin besser
spät als nie seit ich da aber gerade in
dieser hinsicht haben sie ja bislang
jede vorsorge verweigert und sie haben
auch unseren koalitionsvertrag entdeckt
schön da stehen
für
morgen
das gesetz standards für gefahren und
risiko karten mit kfw förderung für
hochwasser und starkregen vorsorge ihr
antrag aber liebe kolleginnen von der
union liest sich wie das who s who was
sie in den letzten 16 jahren ihrer
regierungsverantwortung alles nicht
gemacht haben und statt einer stärkung
des präventiven waldschutzes haben sie
pauschal flächenprämien verteilt ohne
damit widerstandsfähige residente wälder
oder waldbrand prävention voranzubringen
wir kennen es ausdrücklich an wenn auch
sie jetzt neue antworten suchen aber in
einigen punkten bleiben sie sich ja dann
doch treu und wollen die ollen kamellen
aus der mottenkiste wolf und biber
bekämpfen ist ja ihr alt bekanntes lied
neu ist jetzt aber dass sie die gleiche
melodie jetzt auch in der tonart
klimaanpassung singen wollen nutzen wir
doch die bestehenden möglichkeiten in
problemfällen voranzugehen stadt dass
sie uns jetzt auch noch zwei weitere eu
vertragsverletzungsverfahren ein drucken
nächster punkt sie wollen mit wunder
pflanzen aus der retorte ihre
versäumnisse in sachen klimaschutz
züchtungen agrarpolitik wettmachen
träumen sie weiter schauen sie doch was
ihre wunder technik da gerade real auf
den markt bringt einen gen raps derbe
gegen noch mehr unmengen des pflanzen
killers glyphosat resistent ist damit
man noch mehr davon auf den äckern
ausbringen kann was ist dabei
klimaanpassung das einzige was da
angepasst hat sind die aktienkurse aktiv
hersteller
und dann und dann ist die union auch
noch für die renaturierung von mooren
chapeau sappok das ist auch nötig für
den klimaschutz und bestandteil unseres
aktionsprogramms aber konsequent sollten
sie dann schon auch bitte seien nicht
dass morgen ihre agrarpolitiker innen um
die ecke kommen und genau das dann als
böse flächenstilllegung brandmarken wir
handeln schon während sie nur nach
problemen suchen wir fördern bereits
probleme zum bodenschutz mit 48
millionen euro
und da fordern sie da fordern sie von
der union die koalition solle ich
zitiere endlich vom findungs in den
handlungs modus kommen ich wäre ja schon
froh wenn die unionsfraktion endlich mal
versuchen den findungs modus käme
während wären sie noch weitgehend im
alten denken verharren wie bei bieber
wolf und co und natur als gegner
begreifen verstehen wir die natur als
verbündete gerade bei der klimaanpassung
aktionsplan natürlicher klimaschutz da
werden wir mit der wiederherstellung von
ökosystemen auch die folgende klima die
folgen der klimakrise abfedern und die
arten krise eindämmen und die
bundesregierung wird mit einer
vorsorgenden strategie systematisch
klimaanpassung und risikovorsorge
fördern und dafür liebe kollegin
brauchen wir klima isolierende kommunen
die gegen wetter extreme gewappnet sind
und weil kommunen nun mal
schlüsselakteure für diese anpassung
sind starten wir jetzt genau dass eine
kommunale beratungs und kompetenz
offensive für die umsetzung von
maßnahmen vor ort und für das nötige
personal schaffen wir dort jetzt mehr
als 100 neue stellen die ersten
förderbescheide hat die ministerin
bereits überreicht und das ist gut so
weil nämlich die klimaanpassung in
völlig anderer job ist als der
klimaschutz ob ich gebäude dämmen oder
andere lampen oben da da oben rein
schraube etwas völlig anderes als
beispielsweise die planung von
schwanstetten und diesen dingen diesen
unterschied denn sollten sie an der
stelle bitte erkennen wir haben nach
wenigen regierungsmonaten unter
extrembedingungen nicht nur gefunden
sondern wir handeln auch während sie
liebe union noch scheinbar weiter suchen
wer sucht der findet wer sucht der
findet das geld eines tages hoffentlich
auch für die union und ihren
klimapolitischen kompass vielen
herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
als linke fraktion die linke
und ich bitte auch dass wir den neuen
redner natürlich aufmerksam
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin
kolleginnen und kollegen 16 jahre für
die union die regierung war
verantwortlich für nichtstun bei der
klimaanpassung und für blockaden beim
klimaschutz und jetzt nach sechs monaten
opposition wirft diese kurt diese union
der bundesregierung vor die ampel
koalition muss endlich in den handlungs
modus kommt ja das erwarten wir auch
aber ich stelle mir eine frage leiten
sie an amnesie
aber kolleginnen kollegen in einem punkt
bleibt sich die union dringt sie war ist
und bleibt die lobbygruppe großkonzern
vor der technischen hochwasserschutz
stadt renaturierung gentechnik stadt
ökologischer landwirtschaft unter dem
deckmantel zum schutz von mensch und
natur wer sich so erneut profite von
konzerne sichern und diesen etiketten
schwindel machen wir nicht mit
und die linke ist überzeugt es reicht
nicht deiche zu erhöhen staudämme und
teure einzurichten und als techniker
rechne ich gerne mal alternativen nach
die größte die viertgrösste talsperre
deutschlands sind an der saale in
thüringen und halten im sommer 40
millionen kubikmeter wasser stauraum zum
hochwasserschutz bereit ein quadratmeter
nadelwald ist in der fläche ist in der
lage 70 liter wasser zu speichern ein
quadratmeter laubmischwald
schafft
200 lieder zu speichern also 130 liter
meerwasser speicherkapazität pro
quadratmeter nachdem weidenbach wenn
also 300 quadratkilometern oder sechs
prozent der waldfläche thüringens von
fichten monokulturen umgebaut werden zu
laubmischwald haben wir dieselben
hochwasserschutz reserve geschaffen mit
der zeit im gesamtsteuerung bestehen und
das ist der richtige weg und deshalb
fordert die linke in thüringen zusammen
mit unser koalitionspartner geben den
waldumbau und wir wünschen uns dass die
bundesregierung die zukünftige im
gegensatz zur letzten die mittel für
waldumbau massiv aufstocken damit wir
deutschlandweit diesen hochwasserschutz
nutzen können und im übrigen
laubmischwälder können deutlich mehr co2
speichern und geben das wasser deutlich
langsamer ab das ist klimaschutz und
gleichzeitig klimaanpassung kolleginnen
und kollegen frei natürlich riesen die
bäche und flüsse mit überflutungs wiesen
und auen verlangsamen nach starkregen
das hochwasser kamen den
hochwasserscheitel deshalb fordert die
linke seit jahren 50 millionen euro für
die durchgängigkeit unserer flüsse für
den rückbau von wehr und klein
querbauwerke die schäden an fischen für
fische amphibien für unsere natur sind
so groß dass kleinwasserkraft nicht
rechtfertigbar ist wir fordern keine
privilegierung für kleinwasserkraft und
die fördermittel zum rückbau dieser
anlagen denn diese verursachen mehr
schaden als nutzen mit waldumbau
renaturierung und durchgängigen flüssen
natürliche fließgewässern gelingt die
klima anpassen können wir unsere
klimaziele erreichen vielen dank
unterwegs mit der batterie 100 fdp
fraktionen
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen sehr
geehrter
der fraktion union halli hallo lassen
sie mich direkt zu beginn ganz deutlich
machen wie sich unterstützer dass der
klimaanpassung eine solche gewichtung
der bei der regierungsarbeit der
bundesregierung in dieser legislatur
zukommt das erst im vergangenen monat
von der bundesministerin vorgestellten
eckpunktepapier zum natürlichen
klimaschutz ist unser gemeinsamer lausig
leid worden der uns bei dieser wichtigen
arbeit als grundlage dient und uns
gemeinsame ziele auch zeit und lassen
sie mich versichern vorsorge um künftige
klima folgen abzumildern wird durch die
ambitionierten klimaschutz maßnahmen der
bundesregierung bereits in großem maße
getroffen meine damen und herren
aber so ein buntes allerlei und wischt
er weiß vorzulegen wie sie es in ihren
antrag zur liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen der union kann ich richtige
gangart seien maßnahmen zur nachhaltigen
klimaanpassung wollen sachlich abgewogen
und gut aufeinander abgestimmt sein und
genau dafür ist dieser bundesregierung
da
in den vergangenen jahrzehnten sind wir
entscheidende schritte vorangekommen zu
erkennen wie wichtig eine nachhaltige
und dem klima angepasst schutz unserer
ökosysteme ist wir alle haben doch die
verheerenden flutkatastrophe aus dem
vergangenen jahr noch klar vor augen die
rolle des hochwasserschutzes und der who
und der hochwasser risikobewertung muss
überarbeitet und neu gedacht werden
besonders bei der hochwasser richtlinie
besteht auch gute nachholbedarf
da ich hier in der vergangenen
legislatur bestimmte risikogebiet der
folgenschwer
nachlässig geworden glücklicher weise
erfährt die klimaanpassung unser wasser
infrastruktur im koalitionsvertrag große
zuwendung die notwendigen versorger
vorkehrungen zu treffen vor allem auch
baulicher natur kann in zukunft
tatsächlich viele menschenleben retten
meine damen und herren
wie eingangs erwähnt ist die
klimaanpassung vielschichtig und setzt
im idealfall bereits daran wo
schwerwiegender
folgeerscheinungen wie verheerenden
flutkatastrophe noch angemeldet werden
können nämlich mal so wichtigen co2
senken wie unseren ohren wie zeigt dass
der moorschutz für umwelt schützen uhr
ein nischen projekt war es längst vorbei
intaktem oder fordern die folgen des
globalen klimawandels ab und sie wirken
präventiv gegen hochwasser und
überschwemmungen und hier schließlich
noch der kreis meine damen und herren
natürlich ist es dabei wichtig jederzeit
eng mit den landwirten vor ort
zusammenzuarbeiten denn sie profitieren
am meisten von den trockengelegten moore
flächen doch auch viele landwirte sind
sich der zunehmenden gefahr des
verlustes des wassers im untergrund
bewusst auch sie sorgen sich zunehmend
um absacken der böden durch massiven
verlust aber sie liebe union sprechen in
ihren antrag vom café förderung für
hausbesitzer und mittelständischer
unternehmen ja natürlich aber wo bleiben
die landwirte wie in zukunft beim thema
klima anpassung sicherlich eines der
größten flächen zu schultern haben eine
verlässliche planungssicherheit und
ausreichende subventionen für die
landwirte der mannschaften müssen
gewährleistet werden bevor sie
bewässerungskanäle zuschütten und
rückbauen meine damen und herren
richtig muss uns auch eines sein um den
gesellschaftlichen wohlstand wie wir ihn
heute kennen zu erhalten wir müssen
aufeinander zugehen und eine klare
proaktive kommunikation verfolgen wie
sie heute zwischen umweltministerium und
landwirtschaftsminister bereits
stattfindet lassen sie uns den erhalt
unserer natur und unseres wohlstands mit
klugen klima anpassungsmaßnahmen an
pocken dieser antrag liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen der union ist dafür keine
konstruktive grundlage dieser antrag ist
einfach viel lärm um nichts
ich vielleicht gehen sie ja noch in sich
herein
beraten sich in der ausschussberatung
ich wünsche ihnen auf jeden fall dabei
viel erfolg vielen dank
[Applaus]
und der nächste redner in der debatte
kasten träger fraktion der spd
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
schön dass wir heute über einen antrag
zur klimaanpassung sprechen denn wenn
uns in diesen tagen mit sicherheit der
krieg in der ukraine und auch die folgen
der pandemie
umtreiben und die politischen debatten
dominieren dann ist es doch auch
tatsächlich so dass wir im letzten jahr
tote zu beklagen hatten tote in
im aartal
weil dort die folgen des klimawandels
für lebens in erschreckender weise
sichtbar geworden sind und da hätte es
vielleicht auch den kollegen auf der
rechten seite des hauses mal klar werden
müssen der klimawandel ist existent und
er ist in deutschland und die folgen
sind auch schon bei uns tagtäglich zu
spüren wir sprechen von hitze wir
sprechen von starkregen wir sprechen von
anderen schrecklichen ereignissen und
deswegen
ja sie sind ja der größte aller experten
deswegen ist es ein wichtiges thema dass
wir darüber sprechen deswegen ist es
auch in gewisser weise gut dass die
union einen antrag vorgelegt hat aber
frau kollegin weisgerber also ich war
bei den koalitionsverhandlungen dabei
und ich kann ihnen versichern das
wahlprogramm der csu war nie thema also
deswegen
reklamieren sie das gerne bei ihren
leuten für sich dass sie das thema
aufgebracht haben aber es gibt bereits
seit langem eine klima
anpassungsstrategie die muss dringend
überarbeitet werden und in den
koalitionsvertrag haben wir uns das
vorgenommen und wir haben auch ein klima
anpassungs gesetz in dem endlich mal
konkrete maßnahmen beschlossen werden
die helfen werden uns auf die fahne
geschrieben das dauert jetzt noch ein
bisschen im nächsten jahr wird das
vorgelegt werden aber seien sie sich
sicher dass das gelingen wird und da
kann ich sie beruhigen es gibt auch
schon ein sofortprogramm das die
ministerin lemke vor vier wochen glaube
ich vorgestellt hat es im zentrum hat
die ertüchtigung der kommunen denn das
ist ja offensichtlich wir können diese
riesige aufgabe nicht als bundesebene
stemmen und die kommunen können sie auch
nicht allein stemmen sondern wir
brauchen den aufbau von know how und
genau das passiert in diesem
sofortprogramm und dann wird auch das
gesetz kommen mit dem wir die kommunen
unterstützen und in meiner heimatstadt
zb
passiert das jetzt schon ganz konkret
empfiehlt werden starkregen gefahren
pläne karten entwickelt man macht einen
hitze aktionsplan man kommt sich um
konzepte zur entwicklung einer
sportstadt all das ist am laufen und
deswegen ist es gut dass dieses
sofortprogramm diese maßnahmen
unterstützt
liebe kolleginnen kollegen wie ist es
wichtig dass wir an dieser stelle
klimawandel klimafolgen und die harten
krise nicht gegeneinander ausspielen es
sind
nicht nur zwei seiten einer medaille
sondern es ist sogar genau die gleiche
vorderseite dieser medaille wir müssen
die synergieeffekte die wir bei vorsorge
und bei der bekämpfung der klimafolgen
nutzen und heben und deswegen da
sprechen wir über renaturierung von
mooren da sprechen wir über
wiederaufforstung der sprechen wir über
klima natürlichen klimaschutz besprechen
allerdings nicht darüber wie man wölfe
auf allen am besten abschießen kann weil
es keinen sinn haften zusammenhang gibt
frau kollegin zu einem
hochwasserereignis zb in einem anderen
teil der republik deswegen 4 milliarden
hat sich diese koalition vorgenommen
werden wir in den nächsten jahren in den
natürlichen klimaschutz investieren vier
milliarden das sind 4 milliarden gute
argumente die wirklich deutlich machen
dass es ein ernsthaftes bestreben ist
dass wir bei der bekämpfung des
klimawandels aber dass wir auch bei den
bei der bekämpfung der folgen des
klimawandels es ernst meinen und es wird
gut investiertes geld seien viel besser
investiert als die mühe die sie in den
antrag hineingesteckt haben und wenn ich
jetzt noch 50 sekunden zeit habe dann
möchte ich neu in ihre richtung sagen
ich habe mich sehr gefreut über den
gestrigen tag als die betonköpfe in der
csu-landtagsfraktion die aufweichung der
unsäglichen 10h regel zugestimmt haben
das ist eine gute nachricht aber seien
sie sich gewiss wir werden genau gucken
ob der ankündigungs ministerpräsident da
nicht wieder heiße luft vom stapel
gelassen hat sondern ob dann auch in der
umsetzung dieser ankündigung dann auch
wirklich taten folgen 800 windräder hat
er in aussicht gestellt in bayern das
wäre tatsächlich ein schritt nach vorne
ich spreche noch die frage warum schafft
man es nicht ganz ab die 10h regel aber
das hat wahrscheinlich
parteiinterne gründe wir werden uns das
ganze thema genau anschauen im zentrum
der klimawandel bekämpfung und auch der
anpassungsstrategie steht der ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien das werden wir
kraftvoll vorantreiben
ihren antrag
werden wir überweisen wir haben dann im
ausschuss ausreichend gelegenheit da
noch viel viel viel dran zu verbessern
alles gut und
der letzte redner in der debatte und zu
seiner ersten rede ans rednerpult bitte
ich den volker meyer ley cdu csu
fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
seit märz liegt also das sofortprogramm
klimaanpassung der ampel vor wenn wir
jetzt den duden nach dem wort sofort
befragen dann erhalten wir die
bedeutungen unmittelbar nach einem
bestimmten geschehen ohne zeitliche
verzögerung
unverzüglich liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen was sich aber diesen
sofortprogramm klimaanpassung entnehmen
kann ist vielmehr eine lose anhäufung
von
absichtsbekundungen von aktionsplänen
von vernetzungs konferenzen der
schaffung von noch mehr bürokratie durch
sogenannte klimaanpassung manager von
erfahrungsaustausch und von vorsorgenden
strategien konkrete spürbare maßnahmen
fehlanzeige
ein wirkliches klimaanpassung gesetz wie
von der union gefordert wird dabei sogar
erst für die mitte der legislatur
angekündigt das wäre dann frühestens im
jahr 20 23 zu spät sehr geehrte
mitglieder der regierungskoalition es
erwartet wahrlich niemand von ihnen das
innerhalb von wenigen wochen das gesamte
land vollständig fit machen für die
folgen des klimawandels aber was die
menschen in diesem land erwarten dürfen
das sind zumindest schnelle
einzelmaßnahmen meine damen und herren
und die können zb ein
wiederaufforstungsprojekt
flächen in wäldern sein oder ein
sofortprogramm für den baumbestand
städten um für mehr schatten und kühlung
zu sorgen das kann auch ein
aktionsprogramm zur renaturierung von
mooren als wichtigen co2 speicher und
sein wie er von kollegen eben selbst
gerade erwähnt wir haben in unserem
antrag eine reihe brauchbarer vorschläge
gemacht nehmen sie sie an
liebe kollegin kollegen der sommer steht
vor der tür und damit ist in absehbarer
zeit auch wieder mit stark
wetterereignissen zu rechnen aber
auf die nächste flut müssen wir
vorbereitet sein und dazu brauchen wir
keinen manager und konferenzen soweit
also es bundespräsident joe biden der
sich hier geäußert hat zu den hilfen die
die usa
auch noch geben möchte für die ukraine
und zur aktuellen lage in der ukraine
wir sind hier noch in einer debatte an
anlässlich der klima anpassen so nennt
ist die unionsfraktion soll hat ihr
einen antrag eingebracht mit dem namen
klimaanpassung passieren zum schutz von
menschenleben der natur und zum erhalt
des wohlstands das klima und der
klimaschutz war ja schon häufig thema
und auch in dieser sitzungswoche war es
auch schon thema weil irgend unter
anderem der weltklimarat einen bericht
vorgelegt hat anfang april in dem er
davor gewarnt hat dass die maßnahmen
doch noch deutlich verschärft werden
müssen und dass allein privates handeln
nicht ausreicht um den klimawandel
aufzuhalten sondern dass es da wirklich
eine struktur wandelung geben muss dass
das dort transformation geben muss von
der politik und eben auch die weichen
gestellt werden müssen damit das nicht
auf einzelpersonen auf privatpersonen
bleibt und die union hat in ihrem antrag
hier mehrere maßnahmen auch
vorgeschlagen weil sie sagt momentan
sind die negativen auswirkungen nicht
vollumfänglich das klima anpassungs
gesetz der ampel das müsste nun endlich
auch kommen müsste vom findungs in den
handlungs modus kommen und deswegen
fordert sie hier verschiedene
sofortmaßnahmen zum beispiel ein
nationales klima anpassungs gesetz
dieser antrag der wird jetzt erst einmal
in die entsprechenden ausschüsse
überwiesen
und dann auch noch hier ein zweites mal
im plenum besprochen bevor dann darüber
abgestimmt wird der sache die fraktionen
spd bündnis 90/die grünen und fdp
wünsche überweisung und zwar
federführend an den ausschuss für umwelt
naturschutz und
nukleare sicherheit und
verbraucherschutz und mit beratend an
die ausschüsse für inneres und
heimat rechtsausschuss finanzausschuss
halte haushaltsausschuss
wirtschaftsausschuss ausschuss für
ernährung und landwirtschaft einen
ausschuss für gesundheit einen
verkehrsausschuss an den ausschuss für
angelegenheiten der europäischen union
und an den ausschuss für wohnen
stadtentwicklung bauwesen kommunen und
an den ausschuss für klimaschutz und
energie wir stimmen da ständige übung
zuerst über den antrag auf ausschuss
überweisung ab ich frage deshalb mehr
stimmt für die beantragte überweisung
das sind die fraktionen der koalition
und die fdp fraktion wer stimmt dagegen
dass die cdu csu fraktion und die
fraktion die linke
enthaltungen sehe ich dann keine dann
ist die überweisung so beschlossen damit
stimmen wir heute über den antrag auf
drucksache 14 98 nicht in der sache ab
die union hat sich hier gleich beantragt
gleich abzustimmen aber der antrag geht
nun erstmal in die entsprechenden
ausschüsse wie bundestagsvize
präsidentin yvonne mag was hier
aufgezählt hat wir kommen damit zum
nächsten tagesordnungspunkt
ist seit dem jahr 2000 wird hier die eeg
umlage erhoben
und angesichts der verschiedenen
entlastungs pakete für die
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher die auf
grund der hohen inflation der
gestiegenen energiepreise
nun doch deutlich mehr geld ausgeben
müssen hat sich die ampel koalition
entschieden diese eeg-umlage
abzusenken und zwar auf 0 schon zum
ersten juli
ursprünglich wollte man das er später
machen
aber das soll jetzt kommen und oliver
krischer der zuständige parlamentarische
staatssekretär äußert sich als erstes
dazu die umlage ist jahrelang einer der
größten strom preisbestandteile gewesen
65 cent pro kilowattstunde noch im
letzten jahr und wir entscheiden jetzt
diese umlage in zukunft nicht mehr zu
erheben meine damen und herren das ist
für die menschen im land die größte
strompreis entlastung der letzten
jahrzehnte und die richtige antwort vor
dem hintergrund der gestiegenen durch
fossile energie gestiegenen
energiepreise die ampel schafft den
entscheidenden schritt zur senkung der
strompreise an dem sämtliche vorherigen
bundesregierung gescheitert sind
aber die abschaffung der eeg-umlage
entlastet nicht nur den strompreis
sondern sie schafft auch
wettbewerbsgleichheit zwischen
erneuerbaren energien und fossilen
energien und so ermöglichen wir das
erneuerbarer strom im wärme und
verkehrssektor
konkurrenzfähig wird dass wir mit
wärmepumpen und elektromobilität die
transformation hin zu einer
klimaneutralen wirtschaft schaffen das
ist ganz entscheidend um das land
klimaneutral zu machen die senkung die
abschaffung der eeg-umlage ist hierzu
ein ganz entscheidender baustein
und darüber hinaus geht es darum dass
die abschaffung der eeg-umlage
gleichzeitig aber auch ein
bürokratieabbau programm ist denn wo es
erhebungs bürokratie ausnahme bürokratie
gab da sind schlupflöcher gesucht worden
und das schaffen wir ab das ist eines
der größten im energiebereich größten
bürokratieabbau programme dass diese
umlage nicht mehr erhoben wird meine
damen und herren und ganz nebenbei
führt das auch noch dazu dass eines der
haupthindernisse für mieter strom und
eigenen stromerzeugung im erneuerbaren
bereich abgeschafft wird meine damen und
herren das ist ein großer erfolg dieser
bundesregierung
und ich möchte an dieser stelle eines
erwähnen ziemlich genau vor zehn jahren
hat hier peter altmaier eine
strompreis bremse verkündet diejenigen
kolleginnen und kollegen die bisschen
länger dabei sind können sich vielleicht
daran erinnern seine politik und die
nachfolgende bundesregierung hat nicht
dazu geführt dass der strompreis
gebremst wurde gebremst wurde nur der
ausbau der erneuerbaren energien und das
hat uns in eine fatale abhängigkeit von
fossilen energieimporten gebracht die
uns jetzt bitter bitter beschäftigt
meine damen und herren die ampel
koalition stellt diese fatale politik
jetzt vom kopf wieder auf die füße wir
beenden die fossile abhängigkeit durch
den ausbau der erneuerbaren energien und
entlasten damit menschen und wirtschaft
in diesem land dankeschön
und ich erteile das wort dem kollegen
mark helfrich cdu csu fraktion
[Applaus]
[Musik]
frau präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen die preise steigen die
inflationsrate ist in deutschland so
hoch wie seit 40 jahren nicht mehr
ebenso die erzeugerpreise verbraucher
müssen sich auf weitere hohe
preissteigerungen einstellen und das
nicht nur bei strom heizöl und gas viele
menschen und unternehmen kommen schon
jetzt nicht mehr mit den hohen preisen
zu recht deshalb ist die abschaffung der
eeg umlage zur mitte des jahres
alternativlos wir als union hatten die
vollständige abschaffung der eeg umlage
als priorität bereits in unserem
wahlprogramm folgerichtig haben wir die
abschaffung der eeg-umlage bereits mitte
februar von ihnen gefordert und deshalb
dürfte es auch keine allzu große
überraschung sein dass wir dem gesetz
der ampel zustimmen werden
unser gemeinsames ziel ist es dass die
mit dem wegfall der eeg-umlage entstehen
entlastung auch beim verbraucher ankommt
im gesetz ist sie eine verpflichtung der
stromlieferanten zur absenkung des
strompreises in höhe der wegfallenden
eeg-umlage vorgesehen diese
verpflichtung sehen wir kritisch warum
zum einen bedeutet sie einen erheblichen
eingriff in die vertragsfreiheit der
unternehmen
aber zum anderen erweist die ampel damit
dem verbraucher auch einen bärendienst
die regelung verhindert nämlich
keinesfalls der stromlieferanten
betriebswirtschaftlich notwendige
preiserhöhung auf den ersten juni
vorziehen am ende zahlen die verbraucher
sogar noch einen monat früher höhere
preise und deshalb an die ampel gut
gemeint ist nicht gut gemacht
werde damen und herren die abschaffung
der eeg-umlage kann nur ein erster
schritt zur entlastung der privaten
haushalte und der wirtschaft sein viele
sind bereits aufgrund der hohen
energiepreise in existenzielle
schwierigkeiten geraten die ampel hat
hier entlastungen für die bürger und
hilfen für die wirtschaft angekündigt
das klingt erst einmal ganz gut schaut
man sich das entlastungspaket für die
bürger einmal genauer an und so tut sich
bei der angekündigten energie pauschale
ein großes fragezeichen auf genauer
gesagt etwa 22 millionen fragezeichen so
viele rentner und pensionäre gibt es
nämlich in deutschland sie alle werden
die energie pauschale nach den plänen
der ampel regierung nicht erhalten ein
viertel der bevölkerung deutschlands
wird einfach mal hinten runter gekippt
das darf nicht sein
ebenso darf nicht sein dass die ampel
unentwegt von der 300 euro energie
pauschale spricht und sich davon aber
durch die versteuerung im durchschnitt
wieder 100 euro in die eigene tasche
steckt das ist schlicht und ergreifend
eine mogelpackung
von der gleichen großzügigkeit im
auslassen ist auch das hilfspaket für
die wirtschaft gekennzeichnet vom
energie zuschuss auf denen die
wirtschaft zu dringend gewartet hat
profitiert nur die großindustrie aus
energie und handelns intensiven branche
unser mittelstand der rückgrat der
deutschen wirtschaft bleibt außen vor
große teile der wirtschaft das handwerk
die familienunternehmen bekommen keinen
energie zu schluss auch sie werden
einfach hinten runter gekippt an dieser
stelle sage ich ihnen von der ampel
eines ganz deutlich die bürger erwarten
mehr von ihnen die wirtschaft erwartet
mehr von ihnen wir erwarten mehr von
ihnen keine mogelpackung mehr
berücksichtigen sie die 22 millionen
rentner und pensionäre bei der energie
pauschale berücksichtigen sie unseren
mittelstand bei energie zuschuss und
lassen sie eine bereiche der wirtschaft
aus und
kommen sie mir jetzt bitte nicht mit dem
argument der hohen kosten die
abschaffung der eeg-umlage kostet die
ampel keine 6,6 milliarden euro wie sie
uns weismachen wollen im gegenteil sie
müssen keinen einzigen cent ausgeben auf
dem eeg konto haben sie mich sich
nämlich per märz dieses jahres bereits
14,6 milliarden euro angehäuft wegen der
hohen strompreise wird das eg konto am
ende des jahres sogar mit einem
zweistelligen milliarden euro betrag von
plus sein und das trotz dieses gesetzes
wenn die ampel also diese milliarden die
den verbrauchern über ihre stromrechnung
abgeknöpft worden schon nicht
zurückzahlen will dann fordern wir sie
auf senken sie die stromsteuer auf den
europäischen mindeststeuersatz und
senken sie die umsatzsteuer auf strom
gas und fernwärme für dieses und
nächstes jahr auf 7 prozent länder
länder wie italien spanien die
niederlande österreich polen und belgien
haben hier bereits vorgelegt und bürger
und wirtschaft umfassend zu entlasten
beides wäre schnell umsetzbar und zwar
das ohne dass irgendjemand einfach
hinten runter gekippt wird
und der nächste redner in der debatte
andreas mehr tretter spd fraktion
andreas mehltretter sitzt im ausschuss
für klimaschutz und energie
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren mit dem kurs auf eine
energiewende haben wir schon lange die
weichen in die richtige richtung
gestellt wir brauchen die energiewende
weil wir den klimawandel begrenzen
müssen wir brauchen die energiewende
weil sie uns unabhängig von fossilen
energieträgern macht und wir brauchen
die energiewende weil schon heute die
erneuerbaren die günstigste form der
stromerzeugung sind die richtung stimmt
aber die geschwindigkeit hat bisher
nicht gepasst gut dass mit der neuen
regierung jetzt die energiewende fahrt
aufnimmt
mit dem so genannten oster pakets
bringen wir eine große beschleunigungs
novelle des erneuerbare energien
gesetzes auf den weg schon in zehn
jahren wird der strom in deutschland
größtenteils aus erneuerbaren energien
stammen saubere sichere und bezahlbare
energie dafür sind wir angetreten das
werden wir auch erreichen
meine damen und herren die absenkung der
eeg umlage auf 0 hatten wir schon im
koalitionsvertrag vereinbart die
absenkung ist wichtig weil dadurch weil
wir dadurch den umstieg auf strom gerade
im wärme und verkehrssektor erleichtern
und weil wir strom einfach und effizient
erneuerbar herstellen können
beschleunigen wir damit die energiewende
entscheidend
gleichzeitig darf aber eine
beschleunigte energiewende niemanden
überfordern wir wollen preiseffekte als
lenkungen instrumente einsetzen wir
schaffen aber auch einen sozialen
ausgleich wo es notwendig ist auch dafür
ist die absenkung der eeg umlage das
richtige instrument weil sie eben sozial
gerecht wirkt haushalte mit geringerem
einkommen geben anteilsmäßig viel mehr
für strom aus als haushalte mit hohem
einkommen die absenkung der eeg umlage
auf null entlastet gerade die haushalte
die sich teure energie nicht leisten
können deswegen ist es sinnvoll die
energiewende über den bundeshaushalt und
nicht über die stromrechnung finanzieren
meine damen und herren bereits im
letzten jahr mussten wir gerade beim gas
einen massiven preisanstieg beobachten
der angriff putins auf die ukraine hat
die energiepreise weiter steigen lassen
und der hohe gaspreis schlägt sich über
die damit sehr teuren gaskraftwerke auch
im stromkreis nieder wir brauchen jetzt
wirksame entlastungen für die privaten
haushalte und für unsere unternehmen
deshalb haben wir ja zwei große
entlastungspaket der auf den weg
gebracht und deswegen ziehen wir die
absenkung der eeg umlage vor
zum ersten juli sinken die strompreise
um 3,7 cent je kilowattstunde inklusive
mehrwertsteuer sind es sogar 4,4 sind so
entlasten wir haushalte und betriebe
schnell und zuverlässig um 6,6
milliarden euro in diesem jahr 130 euro
spart eine familie mit 4000
kilowattstunden jahresverbrauch in der
zweiten jahreshälfte durch die absenkung
der eeg umlage im vergleich zu 20 21
wichtig ist dass die absenkung auch
direkt bei den stromverbraucher den
stromverbrauchern ankommt
deswegen haben wir im gesetz vorgesehen
dass die stromversorger diese
preissenkung zum ersten juli zwingend
weitergeben müssen mit einer ergänzung
der regelung schärfen wir außerdem dort
nach wo sachverständige in der anhörung
noch eine lücke aufgezeigt haben meine
damen und herren
klimawandel steigende preise die
abhängigkeit von rohstoffimporten aus
russland und anderen autokratien wir
brauchen eine schnelle energiewende und
wir brauchen schnelle und wirksame
entlastungen ein baustein zu beiden
energiewende und entlastungen leisten
wir heute mit der absenkung der eeg
umlage auf null
die fdp fraktion hat hier auch ein
entschließungsantrag
vorgelegt zu diesem gesetzentwurf und
dazu äußern und diesen erläutern kann
nun mag bernhard aus der afg fraktion
er ist der baupolitische sprecher seiner
fraktion
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
letzte woche ist meine nachbarin
freudestrahlend auf mich zugekommen sie
hat einen brief von ihrem
energieversorger in der hand der ihm
mitgeteilt hat dass sie ab ersten juli
nicht mehr 33 cent je kilowattstunde
zahlen muss sondern nur noch 27
überrascht hat sie mich gefragt und die
eeg-umlage tatsächlich ab juli wegfallen
würde ich habe dann geantwortet ja bei
der stromrechnung schon das hat sich
aber dann spruch aufhorchen lassen und
ich musste ihr erklären richtig ist dass
die eeg zahlung nicht weg fällt sondern
künftig nur anders finanziert wird
nämlich nicht mehr direkt über ihre
stromrechnung sondern über steuern und
abgaben auf energie
also immer dann wenn sie brot beim
bäcker kauft im supermarkt ihre einkäufe
erledigt oder dienstleistungen beim
handwerker bestellt was hier was wir
hier von der regierung präsentiert
bekommen ist also nichts anderes als
eine mogelpackung die eine entlastung
suggerieren soll aber in der realität
nichts aber auch gar nichts einen
energiekosten ändert und warum haben wir
in deutschland trotz ihres
taschenspielertricks immer noch die
höchsten strompreise der welt weil
selbst nach aussage des
wirtschaftsministeriums windenergie nur
zu fünf prozent immer sicher zur
verfügung steht das bedeutet dass sie
eben zu 95 prozent nicht sicher zur
verfügung steht und wir deshalb neben
jede windindustrie anlage ein
konventionelles kraftwerk mit der
gleichen leistung stellen müssen damit
es nicht eben nicht aus die wenn gerade
mal kein wind weht
so haben wir so haben wir im sommer
mittags meistens zu viel viel zu viel
strom im netz und müssen deshalb unsere
nachbarländer bitten uns diesen strom
abzunehmen und ihnen dafür auch noch
viele hunderte von millionen euro
bezahlen damit unser stromnetz nicht
zusammenbricht werden wir dann in der
nacht wenn gerade kein wind wie strom zu
exorbitant teuren preisen aus dem
ausland importieren müssen und dieser
irrsinn führt dazu dass wir in
deutschland doppelt so hohe strompreise
haben wie in unseren nachbarländern
warum wie und wieso zahlen die auch
sonst nur die hälfte ganz einfach sie
setzen auf kernenergie
belgien verlängert die laufzeiten seiner
kernkraftwerke um zehn jahre england boe
sechs neue frankreich schweden polen
tschechien sitzen sowieso auf
kernenergie und erzeugen damit günstigen
strom und sind vor allem von russischen
energie importen unabhängig
außerdem entlasten sie ihre bürger durch
massive steuersenkungen so senkt holland
die mehrwertsteuer auf energie von 21
auf 9 prozent belgien von 21 auf 6
prozent und in griechenland zahlt der
staat sogar ein drittel der
stromrechnung und was macht die
regierung in deutschland
taschenspielertricks und sonst gar
nichts dabei wäre es doch
und nicht so einfach allein durch die
laufzeitverlängerung unser 3 noch
aktiven kernkraftwerke und die
reaktivierung der drei kürzlich
heruntergefahrenen könnten wir sicheren
und preiswerten strom erzeugen und damit
die kompletten kohle importe aus
russland innerhalb kürzester zeit
ersetzen wir müssen es machen wie unsere
europäischen
nachbarn die steuern auf energie senken
mehrwertsteuer auf null und co2 steuer
abschaffen herzlichen dank
marc bernhard aus der afg fraktion war
das und er hat es eben auch angedeutet
unter anderem fordert die fraktion im
entschließungsantrag alle zahlungen und
begünstigung nach dem erneuerbaren
energien gesetz ersatzlos zu streichen
auf ihn folgten konrad stockmeier für
die fdp-fraktion
und kollegen es ist toll dass es die
bundestags mediathek gibt sie sich mal
meine letzte rede an und dann sind die
ausführungen zur kernenergie diese
getätigt haben abgefrühstückt
und sich
heute fast der deutsche bundestag einen
beschluss auf denen die freien
demokraten seit jahren in der
energiepolitik hin jetzt zeigen sie doch
mal ruhig es ist ja unerträglich
auf dem die freien demokraten seit
jahren hingearbeitet haben die
vollständige entlastung der unternehmen
und verbraucher von der eeg-umlage
endlich ist es soweit
diese entlastung ist angesichts der
hohen energiepreise zweifellos geboten
sie kommt jetzt auch unternehmen zugute
die nicht zu den stromintensiven zählen
und die bisher deswegen auch nicht durch
die besondere ausgleichsregelung bei der
zahlung der eeg-umlage begünstigt wurden
jetzt ist es endlich soweit mit dieser
absenkung der eeg umlage auf null werden
aber auch einige
konstruktionsfehler in der eeg-umlage
endgültig beseitigt energiepolitische
systematische konstruktionsfehler
erstens beispielhaft möchte ich nennen
das die klimapolitischen potenziale der
sektor kopplung jetzt endlich besser
genutzt werden können denn wer will dass
mehr grüner strom in verkehr und in
gebäuden genutzt wird und da sind
entsprechende technologien investiert
wird der muss diesen grünen strom eben
auch billiger machen
zweitens war es von anfang an gesagt
zweitens war es von anfang an fragt
würde ich das
gesamtgesellschaftlich gewünschte
energie und klimapolitische maßnahmen
quasi nur von den stromverbrauchern zu
tragen waren deswegen also deswegen ist
es auch gut dass dieser
konstruktionsfehler jetzt beseitigt wird
und über verteilungswirkungen ja es hat
keinen sinn mit ihnen darüber zu reden
da dürfte die einsicht begrenzt sein
stellt sich ein bisschen komplexer dar
als sie das dargestellt haben also wird
jetzt dieser gravierende
verteilungspolitische
konstruktionsfehler der eeg umlage auch
endlich beseitigt und wir gehen damit
zumindest einen wichtigen schritt in
richtung der beseitigung von
inkonsistenzen in dieser ständigen
parallelen anwendung von mehreren
förderinstrumenten umlage hier abgabe
der besteuerung dort förderung was weiß
ich wo an der stelle will ich noch
einmal betonen dass wir freien
demokraten uns seit langem dafür
einsetzen dass der handel mit
emissionszertifikaten für treibhausgase
wirklich das zentrale steuerungselement
der energiewende wird und zwar auch so
dass eben nicht ständig andere maßnahmen
dar ein funken dieses ziel ist mit dem
heutigen schritt zugegebenermaßen noch
nicht vollständig erreicht aber wir
gehen einen wichtigen schritt in die
richtige richtung
und damit die heute zu beschließenden
entlastung tatsächlich auch bei den
privathaushalten und bei den
verbrauchern wirklich transparent
ankommt sichern wir auch ab dass das
durch entsprechende änderungen im
energiewirtschaftsgesetz passiert
und was bietet jetzt sozusagen der blick
in die zukunft
der blick in die zukunft bietet dass wir
bei der energieversorgung mit
erneuerbaren energien wirklich auf
freiheitliche zeiten zu steuern in denen
wir abhängigkeiten abbauen können und da
lohnt sich wirklich auch der blick in
wissenschaftliche magazine der austausch
mit forschern und auch mit unternehmen
deutsche forscher entwickeln zurzeit
tandem solarzellen mit ungekannten
wirkungsgraden es werden neue formen der
brennstoffzellen in kombination mit ganz
spannenden speichertechnologien
entwickelt das repowering bei wasser-
und windkraft verspricht auch große
potenziale
das heißt die erneuerbaren energien
werden immer weiter konkurrenzfähig
werden und wenn wir bei der kreativität
wenn wir der kreativität bei
speichertechnologien und auch digitaler
steuerung des ganzen stromnetzes und des
verbrauchers mehr raum entfalten dann
achtung zu hause in mannheim würde man
sagen auf masse und das werden sie ewig
bestreiten und vielleicht werden sie es
irgendwann zur kenntnis nehmen dann
werden nicht die erneuerbaren energien
auch grundlastfähig werden in diesem
sinne herzlichen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
klaus ernst fraktion die linke ist der
nächste redner
frau präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren
wie die lage ist sagen wir uns immer
wieder die preise sind extrem hoch heute
75 prozent preissteigerungsraten bekannt
gegeben immer mehr überlegen sich wie
sie das noch zahlen sollen und wie die
haben keine lösung
die strompreise sind zum großen teil
staatlich verursachte auch das wissen
wir und insofern ist natürlich
vollkommen richtig dass die
bundesregierung jetzt maßnahmen
vorschlägt mit ihnen der strompreis
durch die absenkung der oder abschaffung
der eeg-umlage erstmal erst mal weg ist
und damit eine entlastung stattfindet ob
das tatsächlich auch zu einer senkung
der strompreise ist für das natürlich
eine andere frage weil weitere andere
maßnahmen den strompreis natürlich
weiter erhöhen werden
das maßnahmenpaket das die
bundesregierung sonst so beschlossen
dann ist auch nett aber jeder der da
braucht man kein mathematik professor
sein dann weiß man dass die sieben und
vor den nicht ausreicht dass man das
ausgleicht was durch diese enormen
preissteigerungsraten verursacht worden
sind die preissteigerungsraten natürlich
kriegsbedingt auch das ist klar aber
nicht nur kriegsbedingt sie sind
natürlich auch sanktions bedingt nicht
alle diese preissteigerungen haben sind
unmittelbar auf den krieg sondern viele
sind darauf zurückzuführen wie wir auf
diesen kriege reagieren und mir kommt es
manchmal so vor dass ich sagen mir passt
ist nicht was putin macht und deswegen
habe ich mir selber eine reihe
und es ist nicht gerade das ist nicht
gerade eine vernünftige politik meine
damen und herren und sie wissen auch
ganz genau das war auf dauer
es nicht schaffen werden auch nicht als
reiche bundesrepublik deutschland durch
staatliche maßnahmen das auszugleichen
was auf wirtschaftlicher ebene auch
durch die preise dem bürger zugemutet
wird ich sollte es geht übrigens heute
die cdu darauf hingewiesen in einer rede
gehört vollkommen richtig aber wo sie
brüstet dann die lösung
der pop up also bitte märz also da kann
ich nur sagen der sorgt auf der einen
seite wäre so 100 milliarden ausgeben
für rüstung und sorgte auf der anderen
seite zum kannst du hältst die